- So Connor was like
it's 20 minutes home
on a comfy taxi.
- It's quicker, it's good.
- So then we get in the
taxi, taxi's driving fine
and then just some random
police officer just walks out
onto the street and kind of flags us down.
- Four policemen surround
this poor old man.
- And I ask the taxi
driver is something wrong?
And he's like ha ha I was speeding.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host once again Garnt
and with me are the boys.
- That's us.
- As per usual.
- Yep.
- How are you boys doing?
- Good it's the first week we've skipped
of recording on Trash Taste.
- Yeah it felt weird.
- Mm hmm.
- It felt weird because
normally we record on Tuesdays,
people have probably figured this out.
- Hmm.
- Some people have figured out the entire
Trash Taste schedule.
- I think we've mentioned it
in passing.
- Yeah.
- On what we think is a passing comment
people like remember.
- I remember I got a tweet as well,
I was randomly checking Twitter
like right before we're about to start
and someone tweeted at me saying like,
what are you gonna talk
about today Joey? (laughing)
I'm just like (joey hyperventilating)
where are you (laughing) your watching me.
- Yeah and people figured
out the recording order
as opposed to the airing order as well.
(laughing) There's probably
like a watch order,
the official Trash Taste watch order
somewhere on Reddit I don't know.
- Yeah because some of them
get mixed around right?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Cause of sponsors and whatnot.
- Yeah.
- But in general you could figure out
based on who's sitting where.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Normally.
- In general.
- Unfortunately Garnt doesn't
have a guest today with him.
- Yeah that's how you can tell.
- I'm a little sad about that
Garnt, I'm not gonna lie.
- No this is my second podcast
in a row without guests.
- 2021 is different.
- It feels good, it feels
like a weight's been lifted
off my shoulder you know.
- (laughing) Wow.
(laughing)
Just suddenly calling
all our guests weights.
- No I'm just here I just
got the space by myself
on the table and it's just good,
it's good to be on the
hosting side. (laughing)
- Obviously you're lucky right,
that you weren't fucking
hosting with Chris
'cause he kept making me down things
(laughing)
as I was sitting next to him,
he was like go on, go on, drink it, go on.
- To be fair you're a
pussy drinking that sacket.
- Yeah.
- I would make you down it.
- Yeah I would have done the exact same.
- That sacket tastes like shit
and I'm not gonna be
forced to consume something
that tastes like shit.
(laughing)
- Unless it's for a challenge
and I lose then it's my fault.
- Right.
- So how are you enjoying
your Christmas holiday boys?
- Well that's from we're
recording this right?
- Yeah, yeah that's when
we're recording this.
- Preface we're recording this
during the Christmas holiday.
(mumbling)
We've had our Christmas episodes
but we are enjoying our
Christmas holidays right now
even though we're still
technically working.
- I took two days off and
then I was like right.
- A whole two days.
- Back to it then, back to YouTube.
(laughing)
Even like going one day without YouTube,
I'm like fuck I wanna do something,
fuck I wanna make something,
I wanna entertain, I wanna be a clown
I don't know why.
- You're a clown every
day it's all right man.
- It's pretty some deep insecurity
that happened during my childhood.
(laughing)
- That makes me strive to wanna entertain.
- I don't know why.
- Yeah.
- It was nice, it was fun.
I think the difference between
a holiday that is everyone's holiday.
- Yeah.
- Mm.
- And one that you set for yourself
is that when it's like a national holiday,
you're like well fuck I have to.
- Yeah.
- You're like obligated.
- But then sometimes your
head space isn't in this,
you're like man I kinda
wanna take a vacation
but like I don't want to but
then if you do it yourself,
you hype yourself up for it.
You're like I'm taking this time off.
No one's gonna tell me what to do
but on Christmas you're like,
fuck I kinda wanna like make
a video, wanna fuck around.
(laughing)
- Yeah I don't know what it is
about the Christmas holidays,
Well I've always ended up working
during the Christmas holidays.
- Yeah same.
- Because I've had my yearly videos
that probably won't happen this year
but that's mostly what I'm working on
during the Christmas holidays
and then I realized that as YouTubers,
you need to take a fucking break right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah we need some.
- Sometimes we take breaks
during the weekdays right?
- Mm-hmm.
- To us weekends don't technically exist
but I've found that taking breaks
on the weekends feels a lot better
than taking breaks in during the weekdays,
'cause it just feels nice.
- Yeah.
- When you know that
everyone else in the country.
- Most.
- Is on a break as well,
well most people.
- Well except for Japan.
(laughing)
- Yeah except for Japan,
where Christmas Day is
just a regular working day.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And also weekends are a
suggestion to stop working.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's none enforced.
- Every holidays is just a suggestion
- Yeah, yeah.
- To stop working
let's be honest in Japan.
- It's crazy.
- I went up to the north of Japan
for about three or four
days to go see Chris.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- And that was really nice,
there's so much fucking snow this year.
- Did he make you drink shitty sacket?
- No he made me drink good sacket.
(laughing)
- That's an oxymoron for Connor there.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
Also it was the first time ever
I did a proper Japanese Christmas aka KFC.
- How was it?
- It's just KFC ain't it?
(laughing)
- It's exactly what I thought man.
- It's just chicken.
Although it was kind of weird
because Chris had to
schedule it like or book it.
- Book KFC.
- Booking KFC.
- Yeah we had to book KFC.
- What has the world come to man?
- like two or three weeks in advance.
- Right.
- It's also weird you
not only have to book it
but you have to book like a day and time
to go and pick it up as well.
- Yeah.
- Yeah I saw.
- So it's like not only do you have to
come in on a certain
day to a certain store,
but it's like come between a
2:00 to 3:00 pm time bracket.
- Right.
- And we went there
and there was just like
a group of about maybe
five or six families
just lining up to get
their Christmas chicken
from the Colonel.
- I'd rather die than lineup for a KFC.
- Yeah,
(laughing)
we got a full bucket of like
just a bunch of chicken wings.
- As you do at KFC.
- But also at the bottom of the bucket
there was this kind of Christmas cake
or like Christmas pudding kind of thing.
- Right.
- I don't know 'cause I don't
think anyone had a slice of it
but it was at the bottom of the thing
and we're like oh that's a little weird
that it's just been sitting
underneath this like.
- Greasy chicken.
- Greasy fucking chicken.
- That's not where you'd
wanna put a cake man.
- No it was the last
thing we were expecting
at the bottom of the bucket
(laughing)
to be fair
and it was like 5,000 yen for it
and it could feed maybe
about three or four people.
- You paid 50 bucks
for KFC on Christmas.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Three or four people.
- I mean I didn't Chris did.
- You could have had a
nice roast dinner for that.
- Oh no we ordered all the food as well.
- Okay good.
- But we were like
just because it was the
first time for all of us.
We've never had a
Japanese Christmas before.
- Yeah. So we're like you know
what fuck it, let's do it.
And um wouldn't do it again to be honest,
it's just KFC isn't it.
- There you go wrong.
- 'Cause the thing is this
is I think the fourth year
that I've been in Asia
celebrating Christmas.
- Mm-hmm.
- And I gotta say you
don't really understand
the entire hype behind
this the Christmas spirit
you know?
- Yeah.
- I thought that was just a fucking meme.
- It's just a marketing point, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
I didn't understand that until
I started spending Christmas
outside of where countries
that normally celebrate Christmas.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- And you know you can do a lot of things
to make it feel Christmassy
but having spent a few
Christmases in Asia,
I kind of miss that Christmas spirit.
- Yeah definitely felt that.
- Because there's a few things
you can put on the Christmas songs,
and you can put up the tree
but there's just something missing.
I can't put my finger on it
but it just doesn't
feel fully Christmassy.
- Yeah I get that.
- I think it just has to do
with the fact that at least in Japan
Christmas is not a family thing.
- Yeah.
- It's like a romantic thing.
- And also everyone's working.
- Yeah.
- Yeah like I got a delivery
as we were having our roast dinner
and it was like the
immersion breaking Christmas.
- Right.
- That moment where.
- Simulation ruined.
- Yeah (laughing)
I had an Amazon package and I was like
this is not Christmas.
- That's the door on
your red hat. (laughing)
Like I refuse to have this right now.
(laughing)
- Wine in hand.
- Yeah Christmas simulation over,
it was like that Rick and Morty episode
where you're just trapped in
an alternate (laughing) reality.
- Yeah.
- To me Christmas is like going back
and reluctantly having
to talk to family members
about like oh I do YouTube
you know this is what I.
- Yeah.
- I get naked online sometimes you know.
- Like yes I make this much
per year thank you uncle
for asking me for the seventh time.
- You're investing right?
In a pension right?
Yes yes I am.
(laughing)
It felt odd 'cause I felt like normally,
I didn't appreciate Christmas that much
'cause I didn't realize that
there was a really good way
of like in my head at least,
I don't know if this is how I talk,
it was like this is the end of the year.
- Yeah.
- Now go and restart it.
- And then build up to all of this again.
- 'Cause it's not just Christmas
it's that period between
Christmas and New Year's,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That is just like the blank period.
- We don't do anything.
- where it's just like what are the rules?
Nobody knows what's going on.
Are the buses running?
I don't know.
Are the trains running?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Are shops open?
It's fucking anarchy,
and I love that period.
- Google how long can
I have leftovers for?
(laughing)
How many Christmas dinners can I eat?
- Yeah that was like living in England,
that was like one of my
favorite parts of the year.
- Mm-hmm.
- It was just as you said,
like the reset of the year.
- Right right.
- It was like the entire society
kinda goes into cool down right?
- Yeah yeah exactly right.
- Whereas here it's like
business as usual.
- It's just business as usual,
you go out.
- Like supermarkets
and convenience stores are open
literally 24/7 even on New Year's Day.
- My mum won't shut up
about KFC Christmas to me,
she's fascinated by it.
(laughing)
She's like I heard they have
KFC for Christmas is it true?
And I'm like yes they do mom.
She's like wow how crazy is that?
And I'm like yeah it's kinda weird.
(laughing)
To be fair it is bizarre
when you think about it.
- Yeah it is weird.
- All the things that
Japan has no interest in
from like the West right?
- Yeah.
- We bring our finest things they're like,
no no no none of that, none of that
and then suddenly the colonel rocks up
and he's like listen how
about, let me pitch you this.
- Y'all like grease?
(laughing)
- How about.
Let me take this absolutely nothing
to do with Christmas food
and somehow make it a Christmas food.
Like oh my God, how
did they pull this off?
Like I'm sure someone knows
the history behind it,
but like to me even if you
explained to me how it was done,
how the KFC marketing department did this.
- I mean I explained it
to you last time right?
- Yeah but even then, it still
doesn't make sense to me.
- I researched it and
it doesn't make sense.
- It was like the marketing
heist of the century,
I swear to God.
- Yeah.
- I swear in Japan just
normal marketing things
they just don't care about.
There are just like
advertisements everywhere,
don't care about that.
- Yeah.
- Oh there's a collaboration
where I can get my favorite character
poorly printed on a latte?
Oh well 100 bucks, hello.
That drives me insane dude.
- When you see it on paper
it just sounds like a
great Pretender episode.
(laughing)
- It is.
- It's just like how
do they pull this off?
- This is like Heist 5 though.
(laughing)
This is like the OVA episode man,
when they sell Christmas to the Japanese.
(laughing)
- Literally like it is, it's bullshit.
It takes some Oceans 11 shit
with every marketing department
and like they do
collaborations with stuff.
So this is a really common
thing in Japan where
- Yeah.
- They don't just market things normally,
you can't just have adverts.
It's like you have to
collaborate with businesses.
- Yeah.
- Like I went to the supermarket
and I saw like washing detergent.
It was like a Bungo Stray
Dogs collaborations.
- Oh yeah We got one with Levi on it.
- Yeah and I was like
okay Levi that makes sense
but like some shows it's like Why?
Why does Bungo Stray
Dogs have a collaboration
with washing detergent?
- To be fair it works,
I'm a weeb, it works.
I see Evan (inaudible)
I see Oscar's face
plastered on some coffee,
I'm like.
- No, no, no, no.
- I need that coffee man.
- This is why I hate
it because to me right.
You don't go to a fine
dining like restaurant
for example right?
- Yeah.
- And they draw a fucking smiley face
on your hamburger.
(laughing)
You'd be insulted, wouldn't you?
You'd be like, no, no,
no, no where's my steak?
Why is there a smiley on it?
(laughing)
This is the way I see stuff
and like if you put characters on it
or you put these fucking smiley faces.
I hate it when Disneyland
does that by the way,
when they put fucking
smiley faces on your food.
(laughing) Is my food a
joke to you I wanna eat it,
fuck never mind I'm
gonna (inaudible speech).
But like to me you're making the product
seem more childish by putting stuff on it.
So when I see these collaborations,
like most of the time with like,
especially with the anime at the cafes,
I'm like this is all disgusting.
- Right.
- You're selling me a $3 latte
for 10 times the price.
- I'm offended.
(laughing)
- I feel like it's very similar
to what they do in the
West with celebrities
but like you know.
- You don't get like a
Kim Kardashian latte.
- Um didn't Travis Scott
just do like a fucking
- The McDonald's meal.
- A big collaboration
with McDonald's?
And wasn't that insanely
successful as well?
- Yeah.
- Yeah but wait okay first of all,
I'm near certain and
correct me if I'm wrong
they didn't plaster his face on it.
- I'm pretty sure they had
a specific menu that was
the Travis Scott/McDonald's.
- Travis Scott meal
or what it was called.
- But it didn't have like his face on it.
I went to The Promise Never
land collaboration thing
and there was a cafe and you
could get one of the characters
of The Promised Never
land printed on your latte
and I thought okay fine.
- Yeah.
- It's $10 by the way
- when I had that.
Which would be fucking ridiculous
for a subpar latte.
- Yeah but with stuff
like that though.
- But.
- You have to understand that
the fans will pay any amount
of money for that one photo.
- Right.
So then I go to have it
and I go to drink it and
then as I drink this latte
like this film of like the plastic shit.
(laughing)
- That they printed it on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Goes in my mouth and
I'm like (throwing up)
like God it's disgusting, it's vile
and I don't wanna have to peel
shit off my coffee to eat it.
So I'm here scooping it out
ruining this picture they printed on it.
- Yeah.
- And I just ended up hating all of it,
I don't care how much of
a fan I am of something,
I don't want that shit
printed on my food or drink.
- Oh I mean that's kind of on you then
for going to that cafe right?
(laughing)
Like you could have easily
just gone to a Starbucks right?
- But the thing is if you go
to the exhibition or whatever,
you go to these things there
normally not that like,
there's like enough there
if you're a fan right?
- Yeah.
- But then you have to obliterary
go to the gift shop and
cafe 'cause you know.
- Yeah of course.
- You have to
the gift shop sometimes
has some good stuff
but some stuff that I don't care about
like they're obsessed with
making coasters of characters.
- It's not just the coasters,
I've noticed that as well
because they're putting
Gacha into it as well.
- Yeah.
- It's a blind box of coasters
yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So if you wanna collect the
character you actually like,
you gotta buy more shit right?
- Yeah.
- You gotta buy an extra meal.
'Cause that was exactly the same thing
as when I went to the Fate Museum as well.
- Scams man.
(laughing)
Scams.
It's like being a kid all over again
with the Happy Meal Toys.
- Yeah.
- Man I remember one time
Burger King were doing this collaboration
with like SpongeBob toys and
I was like mum listen this is
the third Patrick.
- I need to go
destroy my body.
- This is the third
Patrick Star I've had mum
can you please go and
do like a Karen thing
and get me the other toy and she was like.
- Yeah my parents used
to do that all the time.
- She would always go up and ask
but sometimes they'd be like no.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I've never heard of someone saying no.
- Really?
- They're usually just like whatever,
I don't get paid enough to find it.
(laughing)
- Yeah exactly right.
- And he's like, I don't
control the Gacha. (laughing)
I just fucking give it
to you, I don't care.
I get paid $6 an hour,
ima just give it to you.
- But yeah I'm not a big fan
of the collaboration cafes,
I just feel like you don't really get
that good of an experience of the show.
- I feel like collaboration
cafes are a bit.
- Shit.
- A bit tacky.
- Just say it just say shit, it's shit.
- It's shit, it's shit.
- Yes it's tacky.
I feel like most anime
cafes are like that.
I've never been to like an anime cafe
and been impressed by it.
- No.
- It's like you go into this room
that's like a normal sized cafe
and you're like oh they've
just plastered paintings
of the characters and
the show's on the wall,
wow look at that.
- It's like they
don't even get creative with it.
Like I would say I've been to quite a few
because Aki likes to do videos on it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah
- I've only ever been to
two collaborative cafes
where I was just like I would go back
- Yeah.
- And that's the Pokemon
cafe and the Kirby cafe
but that's just because
Nintendo has just so
much bigger of a budget.
- Yeah.
- That they can afford
to get a little more
creative with it right.
- Yeah there's so many of them,
you go and watch a
YouTube video of someone
like go into a cafe and it's like,
you could see these
YouTubers desperately trying
to get like seven
minutes out of this cafe.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- At the end of the day it's just like
it's literally just paintings on a wall
and something.
- Yeah I went to
the Weathering With You cafe
and that shit was so fucking lame.
(laughing)
- It causes the same formula every time.
- Yeah.
- And if you come to Japan,
come to like one anime cafe
and then realize that that's
the experience for every cafe.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- The way I see it is that you come once
as a tourist and you're like that was cool
and then you just don't go to any others
- Yeah.
- Because they're all the same.
- Which is, go on.
- No, no I was gonna say like also
how they get you with
all these anime cafes
is that they're only open for
limited amounts of time right?
- 'Cause they wouldn't fucking make money
if they've shut down.
- Yeah.
- Yeah there's a sense of
urgency where it's like,
oh The Promised Never land cafe
is only open for two weeks.
- Yeah.
- I mean I want Promised
Never land let's go.
(laughing) And then you go
and you get disappointed
and before you can file
a complaint it's gone.
- The food was vile as well.
- Oh they usually are.
- Of course it is
it's all microwave food or whatever.
- The Kirby cafe though
had some really good food.
I was actually like
wow I would actually go back.
- I've never had someone
be like you must try this souffle,
(laughing)
You must go to the square
Innings collaboration cafe
for the best, it's like no.
- Listen 'Cause it's not
like going to the JoJo bar,
where there was obviously
like a fan of JoJo,
who would personalize these
cocktails and these drinks.
It's a bunch of corporate.
- It's all sponsored.
- It's all corporate
businessmen stamping like,
hmm yes collaboration.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What can we do?
Coasters let's print
the character on a latte
and put some anime posters up.
- Yeah.
- And then sell a bunch of clear files.
(laughing)
- I realized we're probably
like breaking so many dreams right now
(laughing) by explaining
how shit they are.
- Yeah.
- Listen if you come
here on like a visiting,
you'll probably find it interesting
if there's a show you really like
but in general.
- But 90% of them
are really lame.
- They're really underwhelming
- Yeah like the cafe is
always the lowest point
to any big anime event
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I went to the Fate Cafe
but that was The Fate Cafe
- Of course you did.
- In The Fate Museum and the museum,
the exhibition actually
was fucking awesome.
- Yow yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- Yeah 'cause you got to see
the entire fucking
history of this franchise.
Like of not just Fate but
the entire Type-Moon Universe
and everything like
that and the Nasuverse.
- Yeah see that's cool if it's like,
'Cause I went to the Konasuba Cafe.
- Yeah.
- But that was in par
with the Konasuba movie.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- So you can only go to this cafe
if you bought tickets to the movie.
- Yeah.
- So that was like oh okay you know,
it's like a little bonus thing
but I wouldn't go all
the way to central Tokyo
(laughing) to go to a
fucking Konasuba Cafe.
- No, no, no.
- No way.
- Like it's just not worth it.
- I definitely wouldn't recommend
going to any pop-up cafes.
If something's limited-time,
- No, no.
- Then they have not put effort into that.
- Dude the best cafe I went to
is actually the one I made a video on,
which is like the 3D Latte Art.
- Yeah.
- That cafe is so fucking good.
- And way to suck your own dick there.
- Yeah wow.
Just like ima say that
you know in a good cafe
I bet you it's the one
that I made a video on.
- Well no, (laughing)
'cause I wouldn't make a video on it
if I didn't think it was good right?
- Yeah again that's like
a permanent cafe right?
- Yeah that's bad 'cause
you can literally,
the best part about that thing
is that you can take in
like anything that you want
and you're like make it 3D.
- Yeah.
- I'm like they'll find a way to do it,
it's so fucking cool.
- Yeah.
- Also that guy on Twitter shit
posts like crazy, the owner
he's so good, so funny.
- Yeah that's the thing
it's like again the reason
why I like the Pokemon Cafe
and the Kirby Cafe so good
is because they're permanent.
- Yeah they're always there right?
- So every season they're like
oh we can bring out something
a little bit more experimental,
if it doesn't work take it out.
- Yeah Nintendo are
really good at doing like,
I mean have you seen the new theme park
they're releasing in Osaka?
- Yeah it's opening February right?
- My God, I saw a picture
of that and I thought,
wow Lego land's really
improved, hasn't it?
'Cause I didn't think
it was real at first.
- I usually hate amusement parks.
- Oh no I'm going.
- But this the first time
I'm like yeah I'm going.
- Well because you wanna go now,
before it opens up to tourists.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
- 'Cause it's gonna be hell.
- But knowing Japan
it's gonna be another fucking
lottery to get those tickets.
- Oh.
- Oh God.
- And I fucking hate that,
have we talked about that?
- No I don't think
we've talked about that.
- So I watched the video
of what's the guy's name?
Shigeru Miyamoto.
- Yeah.
- Like giving a tour of it
and you get like a bracelet
that you can like hit shit with
and like there's like keys and stuff.
- Really?
- Dude it looks badass.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like I felt like a ten year old
watching him like talk
about it, I'm like yow.
- I saw a Japanese YouTuber
who got like first
access ever as a YouTuber
- Oh my God.
- Wow.
- It's Hikakin the Japanese YouTuber.
- Ah of course Of course.
- But he's been sponsored by
USJ and Nintendo in the past.
- Yeah.
- Well he's literally like
Japan's like YouTuber,
Oh Hikakin.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause was one time I had a policeman
that was asking me like What do you do?
And I was like YouTuber
and he was like oh, like Hikakin?
- It's like no not like Hikakin.
- I'm like yeah Hikakin man,
like yeah dude, yeah whatever.
(laughing)
Like Hikakin and YouTube
are like synonymous,
- Yeah.
- Yeah pretty much.
- We've never talked about
the lottery system.
- The lottery system.
So this is how you get
tickets in Japan basically.
- Yeah.
- Would you wanna explain it?
- This is better than scalping.
- Scalping?
- Scalping is people who
buy a shit-ton of things.
- And then just jack up the prices.
- Oh I mean no people do that too here.
- It's in theory to stop
that from happening right?
- Right but like for example
when the Olympics for example,
we don't know if that's
gonna be happening next year.
- They've already
announced that it will be.
I reckon it will happen no matter what
but it'll be interesting
to see how they'll do it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah exactly.
But like with the Olympics
for example, it's so dumb.
So they do a lottery that you enter
and it's like a lottery to get
a certain amount of tickets.
So this is how we did it.
So like when I went to
the Persona 5 concert.
- Yeah.
- It was a lottery system
but it was really weird
because it was like
you go into the lottery to get
a certain number of tickets
and they're different lotteries.
So it's like if you wanna
go in just by yourself,
you enter the lottery to get one ticket
but there's another
lottery to get two tickets
or three tickets or four tickets
and just because you
enter into one of them,
it's not guaranteed that
you gonna get those tickets.
- Yeah.
- But then what it is,
is that you might think,
oh okay so if you win the lottery
then you just get the tickets right?
No you get the right to
purchase the tickets.
(laughing)
- Japan have figured out a way
to Gachafy every process possible man.
- Yeah I mean I also
saw that you could get
some of the tickets but you could only
be entered into some of them
if you bought like a Panasonic device.
- Yeah.
- yeah, yeah.
- So they were like giving
away some of the tickets to,
and I was like What the fuck,
this is a fucking mess.
- And also the shitty thing
as well is that like say
you enter the lottery
to get four tickets right?
But you're not sure if
you're gonna get it.
- Yeah.
- So you want to enter multiple
times but here's the kicker.
Say you win twice right?
- Yeah.
- In that four ticket lottery,
you're forced to pay
for those eight tickets.
(laughing) You can't
back out of that shit.
(laughing)
Like you're actually forced,
even if it's only four
people that you're going with
and you just did another
lottery for backup,
you have to buy eight tickets.
- It's just doesn't make sense to me.
- It just doesn't make sense.
- I mean I understand
in theory why they do it
but I feel like this is like trying
to put out a fire with cooking oil,
you know what I mean?
- It's just the most roundabout bullshit,
time consuming way to do
it and I guarantee you,
Nintendo Line is gonna do the same thing.
- Yeah.
- Probably.
I mean Nintendo haven't got
the best rep at the moment.
(laughing)
They've been like fucking everything up.
- Thanks.
- I can't believe that man.
- Nintendo and DMCA are
like that right now.
- Yeah.
- But the stuff with the smash tournament,
did you see that as well?
That was a while back though.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No.
- Did you not see that?
- No I didn't see that.
- Basically they like just
cease and desisted a big tournament
that'd been going on for a while,
and everyone was like the fuck?
Obviously the net code of
the Switch Smash Brothers
is pretty garbage.
- Yeah.
- So people fan-modded
their own version of it
that's much better.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh okay.
- I think it's called
like Slippi or something.
- And they didn't allow that.
- Because they were gonna use that one.
- I love how it's called Slippi.
- Yeah because it actually runs smoothly
'cause Nintendo online sucks.
- Yeah.
- And always has sucked
and the fact that they pay
for it is kind of a joke.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you don't really
get anything out of it,
like it's awful, it's so bad.
Like I love Nintendo but
goddamn does there online suck.
- Yeah they really need to fix that shit.
- And so they cease desisted them
and then they were also sponsoring
a Splatoon tournament right?.
(laughing)
Guess what the prize was for the,
So they were giving the prize,
it was like a Nintendo sanctioned event.
- Yeah.
- They're giving the top prize
for a team of five versus five
was a $25 Nintendo eShop gift card.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- And then they canceled the event
'cause one of the teams had
something like free Smash
or something,
(laughing)
or like had something
along the lines of Nintendo.
(laughing)
- My God.
- Like for solidarity with
the Smash bros believe me.
- I love how the top prize you
can't even pay for Splatoon.
- You can't even split that shit.
- you can't even pay for the game
used in the fucking tournament is.
- It's just funny because it's like
for some reason Nintendo
just wants their fucking IP's to die.
Like I don't get it.
- Dude Riot Games is sweating man,
they're just like oh
there's a new competitor
in e-sports scene now.
(laughing)
- It's just wild to me
'cause you just see like
the complete difference,
again like you said Riot right?
- Yeah.
- And you have the fucking, What is it?
The Baron Red Bull Power Play.
- The Red Bull Baron Power Play.
- The Mercedes Drive to Victory,
Like they're fully embracing
like becoming sports
and Nintendo's like none of that.
- The State Farm Analyst Desk.
(laughing)
God I remember watching worlds this year.
- It was so funny.
- And it was so weird,
just seeing literally
everything monetized.
- It's literally like
watching the American.
- I say that drinking my
G-Fuel out of my G-Fuel cap.
(laughing)
Thank you G-Fuel for
sponsoring Trash Taste,
then we had a nice header. (laughing)
- Yeah it is funny how it's
become like American football,
where like every single part
of the game is sponsored.
- Yeah.
- And then again you have
the complete opposite right?
Nintendo's like yeah we
don't wanna put any of this
'cause Nintendo could make money off it
if they really wanted to. They
wanna be in charge of this
- Yeah.
- But they've showed no interest in it.
- No.
I mean they're probably already
making enough as is right?
- That's the Japanese mindset, isn't it?
They're like we've made enough
doing it the way we like,
We don't want to make more money.
(laughing)
Which is so odd for a business to say,
because I think what was it?
Like last year
Nintendo was the most
cash-rich company in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Which is insane.
- I think that something is slightly
wrong with that statement.
it's not that they don't
wanna make more money,
'cause from my experience
working with Japanese companies,
they wanna make as much money as possible
but they only wanna make
as much money as possible
using the methods
that they like.
- They like.
- It's not that they
don't wanna make money,
it's that they don't know how
to make money in other ways.
- (laughing) Exactly, exactly.
- Because they're like esports?
What is esports?
- I think it's where if
you ask someone like,
you know if you asked me
Connor you can make $10 guaranteed
or Connor you can make 100 dollars
by you know pushing yourself
and being a little crazy
and it might go horribly wrong
of course every time I'm gonna be like,
100 bucks let's do it.
- Yeah, of course but.
- But the Japanese companies
don't see it that way,
they see that's unnecessary risk.
- Yeah, Japaneses companies
like yeah there's one person
in the company that wants to get creative
but he has to ask 60 other people for yes.
(laughing)
- Yeah exactly.
- And that might take a while.
- Exactly and by the time
they always say yeah,
a new trend's come out,
you know what I mean?
(laughing)
- I get it,
because if you are the
head of these companies,
you don't wanna make 100 odd
people lose their job right?
So you go with the safe route,
but sometimes the safe route can just lead
to being stagnated.
- Yeah but also
it's like how detrimental could it be
if one thing doesn't work out right?
Like again Nintendo is the most
cash-rich company in Japan right?
It's like how much do they have to lose?
- It sucks 'cause everyone
like wants Nintendo to just do.
- Get their shit together.
- Yeah 'cause everyone fucking loves it,
everyone wants to fucking
see a Nintendo game.
- Everyone's cheering for Nintendo,
just to do the right thing.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- It's literally the opposite of EA,
where everyone just wants
EA to keep fucking up
and keep fucking up
(laughing)
to the point where laws have to be made
but with Nintendo everyone
just wants to see.
You know you have those typical shows
where you know the brother
is addicted to drugs
and the whole family is super nice
(laughing)
and it's like come on just,
just please stop, just come on
get back on your feet man come on.
That's the sweet Nintendo.
It's like how many chances
do we have to give you?
how many rehabs do we
need to put you through
to see you get back on track goddammit?
- Especially after all the fucking W's
that they will taking in
these last couple of years.
- Yeah they were killing it.
- They were just like killing every E3,
everyone was like yep Nintendo King.
- Yeah exactly.
- Yeah.
- Fuck everybody else and
now they're just like,
We haven't had an L in awhile
let's give out a couple of L's.
- People fucking lost their shit
when they brought out literal cardboard.
(laughing)
- Oh yeah.
Like this is a company
that can release cardboard
and we'll eat it up.
This is how much.
- The Nintendo Labo right.
- We want them to get W.
- (laughing) I completely
forgot about that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah like okay at the end of the day,
they do like the coolest
fucking shit, no other company.
- Nintendo are just doing
their own thing man.
- Yeah like I played
Ring Fit and I was like,
What kinda crack head
came up with this idea
to like just fucking exercise with a ring
and like it works
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's good.
- And it's fun.
like who came up with this shit?
This is insane, You would never see this
from any other company.
- It seems like creatively
they will take any fucking risks possible.
- It's nuts yeah.
- Yeah.
- But like on a business
sense they're like,
No, no we do.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not do business here.
We only make things
business is not allowed.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
When you use the bathroom,
you can always close the
door behind you right?
- No.
- No never.
- You can never?
- I actually never do it.
- Oh my God.
- Poop proud with the door open.
- Well fuck, that kind of
fucks up the next line of this,
(laughing)
but I'm gonna say it anyway.
You don't want a random
passerby looking in on you
unless you're these boys.
So why would you let people look in on you
when you go online?
Using the internet without
Express VPN is like going
to the bathroom without closing your door.
- That's a nightmare.
- Did you know that your
internet service provider
like Comcast or Verizon note
every single website you visit?
- I didn't Connor but thank
you for letting us know.
- And what's worse I'm told
is that they can sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants,
who will use your data to target you.
- I don't believe it.
- But don't worry Express
VPN can put a stop to that,
it creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
- I use express VPN on all my devices.
It works on everything:
phones, laptops even routers.
So everyone who shares your Wi-Fi.
- And the best part is using Express VPN
is as easy as closing the bathroom door.
You just fire up the app,
click one button and you're protected.
Express VPN is the world's
number-one-rated VPN
by CNET, Wired, The Verge
and countless others.
- So if you're like me,
believing your online activities
should be your business
like when you take a shit,
(laughing)
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com/trashtaste today,
that's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
- Where you can get
extra free three months.
- That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
Link's down in the description below.
- I think the creative,
they obviously trust their
creative people at Nintendo
and they obviously let
them do the crazy ideas.
Like they released the Mario Kart AR,
did you see that?
- No.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You basically get your own RC cars
with cameras in them that connect to.
- Oh no I saw that.
- Which is again another crazy fucking.
- It's fucking cool.
- It's so cool.
99% of people can't do this
'cause I don't have the living room space.
I actually do but I mean,
most people.
- You can't be both.
- Yeah also the thought of
having to put a track down
and then clean it up.
- Yeah exactly.
- You know.
- I mean you know just the whole concept
of Mario Maker right?
- Yeah that's fucking awesome.
- Clearly they're embracing
their fans' creative side.
- God I love watching Mario
Maker videos on YouTube.
- Yeah it's fucking cool.
- They were so fun.
- But at the same time they're like,
Mario Party Online no never heard of that.
- Oh!
- Oh.
- That is the biggest missed
opportunity they've ever done.
- You just said three magical words
that I didn't think I needed to hear
and then I was just like,
Why have I never thought of this before?
- It's like that meme of like
whisper the three sexiest
words into my ear.
(laughing)
Mario Party Online.
- I can't believe they
released Super Mario Party
in 2018 was it?
- Yeah.
- And it didn't have online play
and had like four maps
and they were shit sorry.
- Yeah.
- I was so disappointed
'cause I fucking love Mario Party.
- I mean Mario Party is still good LAN
but you know online
would be fucking amazing.
- I don't know if you
guys play Mario Party but.
- Do you feel that some part
of the Mario Party experiences
being next to each other
and just sharing with people?
- No I get that.
- But I would like the option especially.
- To play online.
- For streaming right?
If I need to you got a better option.
- But also it's the same
thing with Smash right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah playing Smash
LAN next to your friends
and shitting on them IRL is fun as fuck.
- Yeah.
- But we very quickly found out
that online is also just as fun.
- Especially on like a discord call,
like that shit's fun as fuck.
(laughing)
- It's just sad, I feel like
they just hate happiness
sometimes Nintendo.
(laughing)
And I thought when Super
Mario Party released,
it's giving way too much detail,
it had like four maps and they
were all mid and I was like,
Okay well they'll release new ones right?
They'll update it.
(laughing)
They'll have DLC right?
- What a fucking lie it was.
- Yeah so that never happened.
Fuck dude I'm still sad about that.
- Yeah I know.
- God that game could
have been something good.
- I'm always just hoping next Mario Party
is the one that's gonna be online.
- The problem with it is
everyone else are playing chess
and they're just playing
fucking hungry hippos
(laughing)
or something like that
and sometimes it's fucking fun as fuck
but other times you're just like,
can you just go back to
like a little bit of chess?
You know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Play by the rules just
a little bit you know?
- I don't get it because you know,
we live in Japan and
they developed the games.
I do not know of any Japanese people
who go around to each other's houses.
(laughing)
- What do you mean?
- You never hear of
Japanese people meeting
in the other people's houses.
It's always at an
Izakaya or another place.
- [Meilyne] Maybe it's cause you
don't have that many friends.
- Yeah maybe it's just because
you don't have that many Japanese friends.
- Oh the ones I do have never do that.
- Oh I do that with my Japanese friends.
- Do you actually?
- Yeah.
- I stand corrected.
- I mean obviously not this year but.
- Yeah but nowhere near as often
as like going out to eat in an Izakaya.
- Oh yeah of course but like
there's been a lot of cases
where I would go out to eat
and then we would go
back to someone's place.
- Yeah right but it's like.
I feel like in the West right?
We are like 90% of the time,
it's like meet up at each
other's house get a few drinks.
- Yeah because it's quite
expensive to eat out in the West.
- Yeah.
- Yeah exactly.
- Whereas here it's just as cheap.
- Yeah it's like the
opposite where it's like,
I feel like for a country
that should value what seems
to be like online play more.
- Yeah.
- For some reason they don't include it.
- No because they don't need
more reasons to stay at home,
that's already a big
enough problem as it is.
- Yeah exactly.
- Are you saying that.
- No, no, no.
- Nintendo is colluding
with the government,
(laughing)
to get all the Japanese people to fuck.
- Nintendo is like we're
saving this generation
from more hikikomoris that we'll birth.
- What if Mario Party is Japanese Twister.
(laughing)
They're like this is
how we get them to fuck.
(laughing)
Why is Meilyne's face
look like I said something
super racist there?
- Mario Party and chill.
(laughing)
- They don't have Netflix and chill.
- They'd rather create the next fucking
Tron VR sex machine toy
(laughing)
than they would Mario Party
online let's be honest guys.
- What was the thing we were
talking about before again?
It was the Tenga.
- The Tenga.
- That operates with VR porn.
- Does it?
- Yeah have you seen that?
- No.
- To explain, I can't
believe I'm explaining Tenga.
- Tenga.
- So Tenga is just like
an own-a-hole
or like a flashlight.
- Flashlight.
A flashlight basically,
you stick your penis in it.
- But it's branded so it
doesn't look like a flashlight.
- No it's like really way too
overly stylish flashlight.
- It's a classy.
- Looks like a deodorant bottle.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
It's like a classy pocket pussy,
that's what it is.
(laughing)
- Can't believe you called it that.
- So gross.
- First class pocket pussy.
(laughing)
I hate that word, pocket pussy.
I feel so wrong saying.
- Stop saying it.
- That's why they called it a Tenga right?
- Yeah just call it a Tenga.
But basically Tenga just came
out with this thing where
it's machine operated with like AI in it
and it works in tandem with VR porn.
So you'd put this thing on your willy
and you don't have to touch it at all.
You start the VR porn
and the thing will move
in time with what you're
seeing on the VR porn.
- That's fucked.
- Jesus Christ man.
- I don't want that, that's scary.
I don't want that.
- And I'm just like
go to a brothel bro.
(laughing)
That's the first thing I think,
I'm like just at that point
just go get laid by a real person please.
- That's like.
- You're probably paying
more for that tech
than one session at a brothel.
- I do you feel like going to a brothel
is a bit different I think.
(laughing)
You gotta be the kind
of person who's like,
all right ima go to a brothel.
I get it you know, if
you want sex that badly
but you're too shameful
to go to a brothel I get it.
- Yeah.
You're gonna pay like
I don't know 20 grand,
then it's in your house right?
- Right.
- Just never have visitors over.
(laughing)
- Yeah exactly.
- They'd be like what is
that like medieval device
you have in the corner?
(laughing)
Oh that's my sex machine.
- No dude I saw like a video of it,
it straight up looks
like a torture device,
if you don't know what it is.
- I'm good, I'm good.
I saw that on the news
they had a thing here,
where the government was
commissioning AI companies
to like match people together
because the birth rate
is declining so low,
but then I also feel like.
(laughing)
- Now that's going into
like dystopian worlds now.
- Yeah but then I can't.
- That's some JoJo.
- You can't have a world that exists
where we're AI-matching each other
but then also having sex machines
that cater for your every need.
- Yeah right?
- 'Cause why would I sign up
to the AI matchmaking service?
- Like 50 Shades of Gray
in like 2050.
- Yeah.
- It's just like this guy just brings
out his VR sex machine.
(laughing)
- Rolls it in on a trolley.
- Why would I sign up
for an AI matchmaking.
- Which Tanga would you like?
- He's not romancing a real girl,
he's romancing an anime girl.
(laughing)
- Why would I need to
sign up for AI matchmaking
when I have the like Cum
tron 7,000 in my office,
you know what I mean.
- What even would the AI determine?
Like how do you even determine that shit?
- Hmm I don't know.
- Your star signs seem
to be matched very well,
Capricorns and Sagittarius
tend to fuck very roughly.
- Knowing the Japanese it'd
probably be something like,
- Blood type.
- Oh it'd be blood type,
earning and male to female and
it'll be right that's good.
You're compatible with
half the population,
fantastic.
- Yeah.
- Nothing has changed.
- I don't get Japan's
obsession with blood types man.
- That's weird.
- Yeah, what is.
- Do you know your blood type?
- I don't know.
I do not know my blood type.
- I don't know my blood type.
- I know, I think I'm O I think.
- Is that good?
(laughing)
- Well I mean, I know there's
three different types right?
There's O, A, B and AB.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and AB is the rare one right?
- AB is the rare one.
- I mean I should know because
I have like a blood disease,
so I used to have a medical bracelet.
(laughing)
- Yeah you probably should know.
- Yeah you probably should
know, shouldn't you?
- I used to have a medical bracelet
that would be like, you know,
if I am bleeding please give
me this thing specifically.
- Do you know what your parents are?
- No.
But then I lost the medical bracelet,
so I don't know where it is.
(laughing)
- The one thing you
probably shouldn't lose.
- So I haven't got a replacement,
it's been a few years
now so it's just kinda.
- Were you meant to like wear that always?
- Not meant to, it's just like
a suggestion from the doctor.
(laughing)
- What blows my mind
though is that in Japan,
at least in like Japanese schools,
like you can get bullied
for your blood type.
- Damn man, that's next level bullying.
- It's like oh you're an A-type right?
- That's just racism with extra steps man.
- Yeah that does sound like an excuse,
it's like I bet he's a filthy O-type.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
You can't hang out with us O-types
because you're an A-type right?
- Why does everyone know
each other's blood type?
- [Meilyne] You'll find out next month.
- Yeah I think.
- Yeah.
- It's because like when you
do health checks checkups.
- Oh yeah we did that.
- Yeah.
- I haven't done mine yet.
- Yeah we can talk about that.
- Oh my God.
- It should be written
on your thing.
- That was so strange.
- So to explain since we're
starring with GeeXPlus,
we are technically under
their health insurance
and their company policy is that we have
to get a health checkup once a year.
- Which everyone in
Japan has to do as well.
- Which everyone in Japan has.
- [Meilyne] Twice a year.
- Twice a year okay.
- Twice?
- We've been here for
one year already Meilyne
but we've only had one
checkup, how does that work?
- [Meilyne] You're YouTubers.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- Well that was good wasn't it?
- Okay so we're supposed.
- Very professional.
- To go twice but we've
only just been once
and it was weird because.
- Yeah true so.
- It was weird seeing how efficient
a health system can be.
(laughing)
- Yeah how long did it take?
'Cause I haven't gone yet.
- It took about 20 minutes to get.
- It was like 30, it was like 30.
- Okay well 30
- Still that's fucking quick.
- So in 30 minutes you do an X-ray,
your blood pressure, you get weighed,
you get blood taken, you do
a hearing and psych test.
- Yeah.
- You talk to a doctor who'll talk to you.
- And then you do a cardiogram.
- And a cardiogram.
- Yeah.
- Wow in 30 minutes.
- All in like 30 minutes.
- All in 30 minutes
- Fucking hell.
- It was like speed running.
We were speed running health checks
and they even had like
fucking splits as well.
(laughing)
- Because it was just like.
- Go and split on that X-ray.
- All right X-ray split done,
all right blood taking split let's go.
It literally felt like that
'cause I was about like.
Because I had some problems with my form,
so I had to fill out my form again.
- Hmm.
So I was only about like 5
to 10 minutes behind Connor.
- Yeah.
- And by the time I had
just started my like.
I'm gonna call it.
- Yeah I was literally done.
- I'm gonna call it a conveyor belt,
'cause that's what it felt like.
It felt like I was in
chicken run being processed.
(laughing)
So I had just started the process
and Connor was almost done.
- Wow.
- It was the most efficient.
- Because I saw the list of all the things
that get checked up and I was like,
oh this is gonna be like an all day thing.
- Yeah you also have
to pee the night before
and bring it with you,
which I just I always
feel weird carrying my.
- Oh yeah I do have to do that.
- Carrying a vial of my piss.
- A vial of piss yeah.
- Who knows what might arise.
(laughing)
So you go into this room
and it's like this really
busy place in like Shinjuku,
which I imagine a lot
of people would go to
if they were in Japan.
- Yeah.
- And then there's like.
you go to this reception
area that's like 12 desks,
they're like all right come here,
you hand the form they're
like right go upstairs,
you go upstairs, everyone's
in like medical downs.
- Yeah.
- Then like a really fancy
office looking thing.
- All right.
- It's really odd and it's
basically just a small room
not even that big with
like couches in the middle,
and then you can see the like sections,
like it's a food court
of like what's gonna do what.
(laughing)
You can see everyone
getting their blood taken.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
- You see everyone
doing everything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then they're like all right
go in this room get changed.
So you put the medical
gown on you come back in
and then they're like
right you have a number.
So you are literally like a chicken
in a farm.
(laughing)
- It's like actually chicken right?
- Yeah it is, it is.
- You literally are like a
piece of meat being passed
around the different things.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- You gotta get it sanitized you know,
(laughing)
and so you just,
they basically just come in they're like,
number 124 and then you go in
and then you just have to
like hopefully understand
what they're saying
in Japanese
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- And then they tell you.
Yeah it was just fast, it
was like boom, boom, boom.
- Wow.
- But I was like,
Fuck dude I hate blood tests,
I hate getting my blood taken.
- Yeah.
- God I haven't done that in a while.
- And then I was like, I was just.
- [Meilyne] Joey you should do it.
- Yeah.
I gotta do my next week yeah.
- It's fun.
- Is it?
- No it's not.
(laughing)
- It's as fun as a health check can be
because it was something
that was so alien for me,
especially coming from the UK.
- Yeah it was really fast.
- Which you know big up the NHS
for giving everyone free healthcare
but the price you pay for that,
is that you have to wait for everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And when I say everything,
even just going to the fucking GP,
sometimes you're like.
- Yeah.
- You got a fever or
something I've phoned up my GP
and they're like oh we can't.
- Six days.
- Yeah we can't book
you in until next week
and I'm just like great
I guess i'll just try to sleep off
this fever then.
- I guess i'll be sick
for an entire week then.
(laughing)
- And by the time you can
see the GP you've already,
most of the time you've already recovered.
- Yeah.
- I think I never see the doctor in London
but I booked three times to see it
when I was like dying and every
time before the appointment,
I got better and I had to cancel it.
(laughing) 'Cause it was
like I'm already better.
- Right.
- 'Cause like
it literally takes a week.
At least in London it's even, it's worse,
but I remember like, I think I fell,
I broke my arm one time when I was a kid
and I was in the emergency
room and I'm like,
fuck dude I'm gonna have to get an X-ray
and they're like yep so come
back in a week and a half
and we'll give you an
X-ray and I'm like What?
(laughing) Like What am I
supposed to do in a week?
What about my arm?
(laughing)
They're like you'll just come
back in a week and a half,
I'm like but what I do till then?
(laughing) They're like oh
just don't do anything to it,
I'm like what do you mean
don't do anything to it?
I mean want am I supposed
to do for a week and a half?
Not move my arm?
So stupid man.
- Well.
- Yeah and it was so weird
going to the Japanese health checkup
and they started off with the X-ray,
'Cause like when I think X-ray,
in my head I'm just like,
I'm not getting an X-ray
unless it's something serious,
So this is obviously like the big checkup,
this is the X-ray but no
they fucking lubed us up
with a fucking X-ray man.
Like we went in there.
- Oh yeah.
- They'd go please go
to the X-ray machine.
- It's just like a rectangle on a wall
and you just put your chest against it.
- Yeah.
- It was really odd.
I've never had that.
- Oh 'cause when I imagine X-ray,
I imagine like the lying down.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've always had that.
It was bizarre.
- I've never had an X-ray done before.
- What was weird actually
was the cardiogram.
- Oh yeah I've never had that before.
- Yeah I've never had that before,
where it's like lie down on the bed
and you kind of feel like a mental patient
about to get lobotomized.
'Cause they put these.
- Suckers on you.
- They put these.
- Oh.
suckers on you and then
they put these appendages
on your heart and your arms and legs.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- And yeah it just kind of feels like
you're about to get lobotomized.
- I was waiting for
like the electric shock
to come or something.
(laughing)
I was like go hit me arg.
but no nothing happened then
they had to lube me up as well,
they do it to you?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They just put like lube on you
'cause I think I had chest hair.
- All right.
- So it doesn't go.
What Meilyne?
- Yeah, yeah.
(inaudible speech)
- What do you mean?
It's a natural medical procedure.
- I'm not talking about my
in-depth colonoscopy Meilyne.
- Meilyne is off-screen
just like blushing.
- Which by the way.
- At the smallest details.
- I was told if you're over 35,
every year you have to have a colonoscopy.
- Really?
(laughing)
- Yeah every year you have
to have a colonoscopy.
- It's because in Japan
hemorrhoids is a really common problem.
- I'm legit.
- How?
- I'm legit serious, I think I
saw something a little crazy,
like one in four men in
Japan have hemorrhoids.
(laughing)
- Yeah Connor was telling me afterwards
that he doesn't want a colonoscopy
because he is afraid that
it'll awaken something in him.
(laughing)
- All I'm saying is like
what if I dig it man?
(laughing)
- What you gonna like crack a fart
on the fucking
(laughing)
surgeon table like.
- I don't know man.
(laughing)
- He's like aah.
'Cause I was momentarily confused
when they said colonoscopy,
I'm like wait, wait, I'm
like which end is that?
(laughing)
- Which end is that?
- 'Cause I thought about it,
would you rather something go up your ass
or down your throat?
- Up my ass.
- I thought up my ass.
- He thought it was
going down your throat,
so they check your throat
or down like your stomach whatever.
- What's that called?
That's a different thing right?
- It's something else
and I was like totally down.
I'm like all right fine
put it up my ass dude.
(laughing)
- Down my throat, Whatever up my ass.
- No, no it's the opposite way.
- Oh the opposite way?
- Opposite yeah, yeah.
- I'd rather something up
my ass than down my throat.
- Meilyne is in disbelief.
- Don't take that
out of context.
(laughing)
- Meilyne, what would you.
I'm kidding.
Also when we were doing
this health checkup as well,
We had like the blood pressure thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- where you put the arm
and like the thing in it,
which also always feels weird.
- The thing that
squeezes your arm.
- Yeah, yeah.
And then the doctor was like,
yeah you did good on that
and I'm like what does
that mean? (laughing)
What does that mean I did good?
- What is doing bad?
Like arg!
- I'm like explain what did good means,
that your numbers are good.
(laughing)
I'm like yeah but explain
the fucking numbers to me,
what is this supposed to mean?
- I put all my attention into my arm
to change my blood pressure.
- Yeah I was doing something
like Hunter Hunted nend shit
on that thing,
(laughing)
I'm like heart rate zero.
- You did like Avatar blood-bending shit,
it's just like.
- Yeah.
I was like I will now
make my heart rate zero
so my enemies cannot find me.
(laughing)
- And then we've got our blood taken
and I remember before
we got a blood taken,
we were talking about you know.
(laughing)
We were talking
about how the Japanese health system had.
We've all had pretty good experiences
with the Japanese health system
because we will all have like.
- Right, right.
- I don't know why, we all
have that inherent fear
that you know everyone's
had a shitty experience
when they have taken the blood
and they've just missed the vein.
Right?
(laughing)
- Yeah oh God.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that happened to me. (laughing)
- Really?
- Yeah, like it was foreshadowing,
that happened to me.
'Cause I knew it as soon
as he stuck the needle in.
'Cause you know you can feel it,
when it goes straight into your vein,
it feels exactly like
the doctor describes,
it's just like a prick right?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And it just comes out,
so he sticks his needle in
and I could feel immediately
that something was wrong
(laughing)
'cause he was like that's
not a vein that's muscle,
and you start feeling pain and I felt,
sorry for anyone who has
like a needle phobia,
'cause I'm gonna, so I can feel him like
kind of twitching the needle around.
- Oh.
- In my arm
and I'm just like how do
I tell him it's not there?
How do I tell him it's
not there? (laughing)
And he does it for like a full minute
before he realizes oh
there's no blood coming out,
and I look over.
(laughing)
- He's pulling up fat.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- And I look over and
there's like you know
like the vial of blood?
- Yeah.
- The vial was filled up that much.
(laughing)
It's like the minute
he was poking my arm and am like.
- It's probably just a scar tissue blood.
- Yeah and I'm just like, God
fucking dammit man, I knew it.
- I felt so embarrassed I was like,
fuck I wanna be cool and
not like shit myself here.
- Yeah.
- But then I was like
oh God and I was like,
oh no the nurse is cute oh no I can't,
I'm gonna make a fool of myself.
- No I think with needles, I
feel needles are the only time
where you can bring out your inner pussy
and just be like I don't, no, I hate it.
- I can't look at the needle going in.
- Oh I have to look at
the needle going in.
- What?
- You do?
- Yeah like it's on the contrary for me.
If he's like all right, we're gonna go in
and if I don't see it
and I feel a prick that scares me more.
- Joey is just like it's going in.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
No Legit.
(laughing)
I have to go hard but,
I'd just be like
(laughing)
do it, do it now!
Come on!
(laughing)
- Wait What about staring at
you being pierced helps you?
- Because I know when the pain is coming.
- What?.
(laughing)
- You know what I mean?
- No that's worse!
- No because then you're
expecting the pain right?
- No, no what's worse for
me is unexpected pain,
where I'm just chilling and
then suddenly it's like ow!
- You barely feel it if
you don't look though.
- No, no, no.
- Yeah.
- I feel it more if I don't look.
- What that's?
- Because that's like, have
you ever like cut yourself
or have like an injury?
You don't feel that all day.
- Yeah.
- And then suddenly you look at it
and you're like wow there's a cut
and then suddenly you start feeling it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
- That's me and needles.
- Really?
Because every time I get cut
it's just immediate pain.
- Like I can't imagine seeing
blood literally gush out
of my veins and thinking yeah
that looks like a painless experience.
- Not gonna lie, like during
the summer for instance,
'cause like during the summer
your blood pressure is a lot higher.
- Yeah.
- So when the blood comes out
it kinda just like gushes out
and I'm just like oh that
looks sick. (laughing)
I like looking at that, it's kind of cool.
I'm like whoa that's coming
out of my body, fuck.
- I remember when I was a kid
they would just give me
this like contraption
that was just like filled
with like paint oil
and it would just like
all of it would like,
you would flip it over and
I'd start playing like crazy.
- Yeah.
- They should do that to distract me.
- (laughing) To distract yourself.
- Yeah 'cause I was like wow
look at that thing go wow hey.
- I just look at the vail and
I'm like whoa that's cool.
- That's weird I can't do that.
- Really?
- I was just like I put
my hand on the table
and I'm like go ahead.
(laughing)
- You smacked it off.
- I was like Kawaii man go ahead.
(laughing)
- Why'd you have to like smack it out?
- I'm like come on get ready boy.
- Belt in the mouth.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- I'm like we using mine or
are we using mine? (laughing)
- Yeah.
- What was weird for me,
because normally when
I get my blood taken,
I'm used to it being like a private place.
- Yeah it was weird.
- You know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
- It was only in front of everyone.
- Yeah and so we had our blood taken,
it's like a conveyor belt
and I was just like
eyeing up the next guy,
the guy next to me
getting his blood taken.
- Yeah there was three of
us right next to each other,
getting our blood taken, it was very odd.
- And neither of us could look
at the blood getting taken
and we just fucking
met eyes and just like,
all right.
(laughing)
- And then we kissed.
- Yeah it's like meeting guys in a urinal.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For you it's just
like sir this is awkward.
How's your day going?
Oh you look like an O-type there,
fuck you mean.
(laughing)
What are you meant to say right?
- Just trying to strike
up any conversation.
(laughing)
- I guess it is odd that we made it
into a private thing in the West right?
Like does it really need to be private
getting your blood taken?
- It doesn't but I feel more comfortable.
- I think it's that people
would prefer it right?
- I prefer it but if that means
that I get medical tests way
fucking quicker in the UK.
- Yeah.
- By all means do my colonoscopy
in front of the other patients.
(laughing) I do not mind,
Like let's get this done.
- It's like oh you cracked
a fart too same high five.
(laughing)
- If that means I can
get it done 20% faster
and I can get on with my day.
- Yeah exactly.
- I'll gladly get my blood,
if I faint in front of a
group of 20 people who cares.
- That's why in my head I was like,
oh this was gonna be an all-day thing.
- I thought it was gonna
be an all-day thing.
- Because a health checkup anywhere else
is definitely an all-day thing right.
I think the worst part
was that you couldn't eat
or drink anything the night before.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- After like 8:00 pm you have
to stop eating and drinking,
- Yeah.
- And normally
that wouldn't be a problem
but when you tell me
I can't eat and drink,
I'm like well fuck now I wanna to.
(laughing) Well now I
wanna just eat and drink.
- Wait can you drink water?
- Oh you can drink water.
- Oh right, I was gonna say.
- You can drink but water is
the only thing you can drink.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can't have any alcohol.
- I was like it has
British people like shaking
Tea, tea arg!
(laughing)
- Yeah basically no
substance in your bloodstream
the night before.
- Why is it substance?
What are you taking Garnt?
Garnt's like fuck.
- You gotta put the belt and spoon away,
it's like fuck damn it.
- Goddammit,
they're gonna see my heroin
veins and everything man.
- It's like Make sure to hit
the heroin vein. (laughing)
- It's like don't worry I got
this, I've done this before.
(laughing)
I'm kidding.
- Garnt's got this.
- And this is a joke.
How does you take heroin again?
You take a pint of heroin that way.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's how
you take it right.
- It's a pint, it's a pint definitely.
- Can't believe the Trash Taste boys
made a light of drug addicts.
- Yeah, well, In case
you don't get sarcasm,
none of us have done heroin okay?
It was just like so wanna make that clear.
- Yet, Unless.
- That's the good dark
art of the Trash Taste.
(laughing)
- No, okay we should stop joking.
- Trailer Trash Tastes.
- We can stop joking about it.
Oh my God.
- I heard you guys had
an exciting taxi journey.
- Yeah so I convinced Joey to get a taxi
'cause Joey wanted to get the train home
'cause it's about like half the price,
but you know it was like midnight.
- It was the day when Connor and I
were streaming at the Trash Taste office,
if you guys saw on our Twitch.
- Yeah.
- but it was like 11:00 pm
when we finished?
- Yeah and I was like Fuck
getting the train home,
Come on Joey let's get a
taxi, it must be comfortable.
it's late you know we just dreams.
- I don't know what you see,
I don't know why you like
have this massive thing
about like the comfort in taxi.
It's not that much more comfortable.
- It's not comfortable.
- Dude it is so much more comfortable.
- You say it as if it's like
business class versus economy class.
- Honestly that's the way I see it.
- No, no.
- No.
- Because also right now
with the Rona going on,
if I can avoid getting a train,
i'll avoid getting a train.
- I understand that.
- Yeah.
- But for me,
like I would most like 90% of the time,
I would rather get like,
have a longer journey that
I can actually do stuff on
because I can't do anything on a taxi.
- Well I can do more on a taxi.
- I look at my phone and I
immediately just get carsick.
- You can't do anything
on a train in Japan.
- Yeah I mean you can
watch YouTube videos.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You could do that in a taxi.
- No, no I can't because I get carsick.
- Because I didn't know why.
- I'm sorry that your natural selection
didn't favor you Joey
that's not my problem.
- Oh wow.
- I'm not the only one
(laughing)
Garnt gets carsick as well.
- Both of you.
(laughing)
- I think most people get car sick
when they look at stuff.
- Yeah.
- I'm focusing on the
YouTube video or the thing.
- It's because you can't see outside
so the inertia just fucks you up.
That's how you get carsick.
- I'm not sure about the
exact science of car sickness
but like cars are the only
vehicle I get motion sickness in.
- Yeah.
- Anything else I can like read.
- Boat?
- Boats.
- Well that's not carsick,
is it? It's sea sick.
- Yeah, that's.
- He said vehicle.
- I don't think I get seasick.
- Really?
I get seasick sometimes.
- I get slightly seasick.
- Of course it's 'cause normally people
who are carsick get seasick.
- I don't get carsick that easily though.
- Unless you're watching something?
- But if I'm looking down at my phone,
I can't read in a car.
- No, no, no.
Like I don't get carsick
if I'm just sitting
there listening to music.
- God carsickness must be hell then.
- Yeah it's fucking boring for me.
- When you have to travel
like four hours in a car,
what do you do?
- God I fucking hate my life.
- I just turn on my music
and go to bed.
- I think that's why
I've conditioned myself
to be able to sleep so easily in cars.
- Yeah.
- Because I literally
can't do anything in cars
but sleep and listen to music.
- But it's weird,
I can do the exact same thing
on a bus and not get sick.
- On a bus?
- Yeah I could be on a bus
and watch YouTube or whatever or read.
- Fucking look at the needle.
- And i'll be fine.
do this shit? Look What
happened to you. (laughing)
What happened?
- If I do that in a car
five minutes in I'm sick.
- I think it's the smaller the vehicle,
the more likely I'm to get sick.
I don't know what the
science is behind that
but if it's like a small taxi,
especially if it's a small taxi
and we're like squeezed in,
- And if you're in the back seat right?
- And if you're in the backseat.
I just get immediately motion sick.
- I don't wanna be in
the front of the taxi,
I don't wanna make eye
contact with the taxi driver.
- You don't have to.
What, you think you're
just gonna fucking do this
the entire ride?
(laughing)
- Well sometimes you know,
you might find yourself
wandering and you look at him
and it's this awkward moment of like,
hi, how are you doing?
- No, I've never done.
- Good driving, good driving.
(laughing)
- I'm awkward, I don't wanna
make eye contact with him.
- I have the same problem in the backseat,
where I accidentally sometimes
look at the rear view mirror.
- No, that's the worst.
(laughing)
- I sometimes look
- That's the worst.
at the rear view mirror.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then I make eyes to
them and then just like,
hi there, hi.
(laughing)
- You just has to do it silent like nod.
- The worst is when they're a
fucking awful driver as well,
you gotta pretend like
they're doing this good job
and there just fucking insane.
- Yeah and that's why I
prefer to be in the front,
'cause I'm less likely
to get sick in the front
from shit driving
- Yeah.
than in the back.
'Cause you're fucking
thrown around in the back.
Anyway the story so.
- Oh yeah, we were talking
about the fucking story.
- Okay we can go back into
taxi (inaudible speech).
- So anyway Connor was like,
look it's 20 minutes home,
on a comfy taxi.
- It's quicker.
- It's quicker and we're comfortable.
- It's quicker by only
like five, 10 minutes.
- We get closer to our house
'cause you would have to go to the station
and walk.
- Yeah.
- Not that much.
- So I was like all right, fuck it.
i'll fucking humor your taxi ride.
So then we get in the taxi,
the taxi is driving fine
and then we go onto this
kind of bridge thing.
- Mm-hmm.
- and then just some random
police officer walks out
onto the street and kind of flags us down,
- Right.
- And tells us to go
into one of the roads,
and immediately the taxi driver was like,
just the Japanese equivalent of Oh fuck.
(laughing)
- He's like this 90-year-old dude,
- Yeah he's old.
- just being like Oh shit
and he pulls in and Connor and I are like,
what the going on?
And I ask the taxi driver I'm like
Is something wrong? and he's like,
(laughing)
I was speeding.
I was like you got stopped for speeding?
And he's like yeah I
was doing 80 down a 60
(laughing)
and this fucking old dude
just walks out of the taxi,
fucking like you know Ozzy Osborne style,
kind of stumbles out.
(laughing)
- Four policemen surrounded
this poor old man.
- Yeah.
And like in the middle of the night,
as he's filling out this paper for work,
and Connor and I are just
kinda sitting there being like,
oh we could have been home by now
if we went on the train, huh.
(laughing)
The one time I humor this
man to get on a taxi.
- Listen that is the first
time I ever had a taxi driver
been pulled over by the police you know,
'cause I was just hoping
that they wouldn't be like,
all right let's have a look,
well these boys in the
back look pretty foreign.
Let's see what's going on with these boys.
- Yeah.
- That's why I was like Fuck come on.
- I was afraid that might happen as well,
so immediately like
before the police officer
even started talking to us,
I just immediately bust out the Japanese,
be like what's going on officer?
(laughing)
Yes I am Japanese.
- The police officers asked us,
they were like is it okay
if we stop you for now?
Like the driver.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And that was like what if we said no?
- Yeah I'm like what are
we supposed to say to that?
Like no, no fuck you.
- We're in the middle
of fucking nowhere,
(laughing)
there's no taxis anywhere.
What do you expect us
to do like walk home?
- They pulled us over some bridge,
So there wasn't like much there,
so it was just like some water,
- Right.
- And then like a bunch of
like a power plant nearby,
so it was like nothing, it was really odd.
- So four police officers,
like fucking busted down
this decrepit taxi driver.
- Yeah just for this guy
and then there was two
other police officers
just standing there doing nothing
'cause that's what they do here.
- Every police story I've heard in Japan
is all about how many
police officers you need
versus how many was actually
needed during the scene.
- They literally send
like six police officers
to like someone falling over on a bike.
- Yeah.
- It's like it's insane.
They're so bored here,
they've nothing to do.
- Yeah they need spotters right?
(laughing)
He's like I got you bro, nice
policing you're doing there.
- 'Cause normally in the UK,
it's always like two people.
Like it's always a squad right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Two people and you know.
- Go one and your partner right?
- Yeah it's normally
how it should be right?
Because also I don't know
if this is on purpose,
but it's very intimidating
when four or five policemen
are crowding around you
and you haven't done anything
and they're asking you questions.
They all look pissed off
(laughing)
and I'm like well come on,
what's going on here then?
- Yeah right?
(laughing)
- What's all this about?
- I felt so bad for the old dude,
'cause he looked like he was
about to get fucking beaten up
by these four police officers,
(laughing)
'cause they're literally were
just crowding around him,
just like looking down at the paperwork.
- I've never been in
this situation as well,
this is the first time
where I've been near police
where they haven't asked for like my ID
and like information and stuff.
- Well yeah because I busted
out the Japanese quickly.
- Yeah, yeah, true.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's so annoying 'cause
you just go near them
and they're like hey can
we see ID and all this?
and I'm like why?
I'm not involved in this,
I'm literally just a
customer leave me alone.
- Well you think I had a
gun pointing to this taxi,
like do 80, do 80.
- Do it, do it, do 80, you sick cunt.
(laughing)
- No like what?
- Start playing European in
the background, hey come on,
Gas, gas, gas.
- Yo drift this corner, drift this corner.
Do it, do it.
(laughing)
I know what I'm doing,
I've done it one time.
This video is sponsored by Mack Weldon.
There are a lot of things
that you'd probably like
to leave behind in 2020,
one of the most important
being your old underwear boys.
(laughing)
(Joey screaming) If you're
rolling into the new year
with the same bunching, chafing
and uncomfortable underwear
then you've gotta check out Mack Weldon.
Mack Weldon is an essential
piece of my daily routine,
thanks to this card holder boys.
It holds all my cards very
neatly thank you Mack Weldon.
- I have a face mask because
I'm scared of the outside,
as should you be.
- Wait Garnt what is
that that you're wearing?
Is that Mack Weldon?
- It is a nice little Mack Weldon fleece.
'Cause it is winter right now,
(Joey inhales sharply)
- Damn!
- And the it's cold outside
and I just want to feel comfortable.
- You're looking fly.
- Thank you very much.
- Mack Weldon has all the
men's essential covered:
Socks, shirts, hoodies,
underwear, Polos and active shorts.
Mack Weldon promises comfort
and consistent fit with versatility.
that look great and feel great,
from working out, going out,
going to work.
- Or even going on a date.
(laughing)
- Mack Weldon is for everyday life.
- Don't forget about the wide range
of technology (laughing) what
the fuck are you doing Joey?
Don't forget about the wide range
of technology of customized fabrics
that can keep up with you
no matter what your day looks like.
18 hours, silver, air knit,
dry knit, warm knit.
- That's a lot of knits
but did you also know, Garnt?
There's Weldon Blue, totally
free loyalty program?
Level one gets you free shipping for life.
Once you reach level two by spending $200,
you get 20% of every order
for the next year Garnt.
- Get out of here Connor.
- It's insane.
- On top of that there is the guarantee
that Mack Weldon gives you.
Do you know what is The
Mack Weldon guarantee?
- What is the Mack Weldon guarantee?
- Well Garnt I'm glad you asked.
Mack Weldon wants you to
be comfortable, Garnt.
So if you don't like your
first pair of underwear,
you can keep them and
they'll still refund you,
no questions asked.
- Even if I've worn them before?
- Especially if you've worn them.
(laughing)
- I'm here too.
- Especially if you've been
a little dirty gamer boy
and not gone to the toilet.
- For 20% off your first order,
visit mackweldon.com/trash taste
and enter promo code: trashtaste.
That's mackweldon.com/trash tastes,
promo code: trashtaste
for 20% off, Mack Weldon.
- Reinventing men's basics.
- Don't steal this line from me Connor.
- Thank you to Mack Weldon
for sponsoring this episode
back to the show.
- But in general I do find
taxis a little awkward,
I don't know as somebody again who thinks
about things a lot socially,
I like to think of like the
perfect social situations.
- What's awkward about them?
- Yeah.
- You talk so highly of taxis right?
- In Japan it's good
because I know they'll,
actually some of them do
actually try and talk to me.
- Like virtually none
of them ever talk to me,
but some of them will.
- I feel like some of the older ones,
they bust out a conversation.
- Yeah.
- Some of the people who also
like, maybe learned English
in college or something.
- Especially I've noticed taxi
drivers in the countryside.
To me as I like
Oh yeah they love talking.
- Yeah.
- In the city it's just like, all right.
You're a customer I'm a taxi driver,
I will not communicate in any way,
shape or form.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's charming in Japan I think,
when the taxi driver is
trying to talk to you.
Especially in English, when
they're trying to talk to you.
It's like oh, damn. you're
putting on the work.
So please focus on driving
but you know go ahead.
- The best taxi driver I
ever had was in Okinawa
and we were going from.
- What constitutes a good taxi driver?
- Yeah that's a good question.
(laughing)
- Okay it was a good taxi driver.
- Wait do you like it when
your taxi drivers talk to you?
- Sometimes, I gotta be
in the right mood I feel.
- Yeah, yeah same here.
- Like you know if it's like
fucking 3:00 am right?
- Yeah.
- And I'm like either
drunk or just tired or both
and I'm stepping in
I don't wanna have a fucking conversation
with the taxi driver.
- Yeah, some sometimes
you get in a taxi drive
and they ask how your day's going,
and I'm just like arg.
- Can you tell by the way I look?
- Here we go, here we go.
(laughing)
- I mean it depends if
I'm alone or with friends,
have you ever had a taxi driver who butt
into a conversation
between you and friends?
- Oh, yeah.
- No.
- That I hate that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait hold up, hold up.
(laughing)
this isn't a social invitation, sir.
- Now the best taxi ride
I had was in Okinawa,
because we were going from our hotel
to this like one castle in Naha
and it was like a 30-minute taxi ride.
- Okay.
- Right.
- And the dude was like you know,
obviously an older gentleman
but he clearly had been
there his entire life,
- Yeah.
- And he knew immediately
he's like oh foreigners,
you clearly don't know a whole
lot about this place huh?
And he started talking
and he took us on this really
fucking scenic route.
- That's pretty nice.
- Like throughout all these places
but he said he's like I
took you on the scenic route
but i'll charge you for the regular route.
- Oh.
- What a nice guy.
- So he was nice enough
so he would like actually
kind of stop the car
and kinda be like this is this,
and it's a kind of cool thing.
- Man's a tour guide,
(laughing)
not a taxi man goddamn.
- No legit
Like he was like a tour guide.
- I actually had something
very similar happen to me
when I went to Koshi Valley.
'Cause we wanted to go to this one.
- Are taxi drivers just
part-time like fucking tourists?
- I think they're just happy
because they just have,
One, they're happy to have tourists there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because I'm pretty sure
business has not been banging
this year.
- Oh yeah true.
- Yeah.
- So yeah me and Sydney
were on this taxi ride
to get to this winery and he's
like let me give you a tour
of the other wineries in the area as well,
just in case
you wanna go to one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah he only charged
us for the taxi ride
to the one winery but yeah,
we got a tour of every winery down there.
- Show me these taxi drivers,
I'm never getting any.
- Again I feel taxi
drivers like that though,
really only exist in the countryside.
- Yeah nobody gets
- Yeah.
- That in Tokyo.
Dude in Tokyo they're fucking miserable.
- Oh, yeah I would be too
to be honest. (laughing)
- It's in Rappongi,
there's a big cemetery.
I'll find it
- Oh, yeah, yeah
I forgot the name of it.
- I'll send you a picture
of (inaudible speech)
but there's this whole area right next
to this giant cemetery right?
- Yeah.
- There's a big stretch of road
and taxi drivers just sleep there.
- Like really?
(laughing)
- There's hundreds of taxis parked right?
And they all park and they all just sleep
and change clothes in this area.
It's on a busy road in a really busy area.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- Which they all just sleep
there, it's so bizarre,
yeah you can do that here.
You can just park your car
on a busy road and just sleep
- Yeah.
- Like people do that it's so weird.
You can't do that in the UK.
- No I feel most countries
you can't do that.
- No even in the
countryside that'd be weird,
someone would come and
slap you and be like,
yow are you okay, what's up?
(laughing)
- Have you by the way seen,
I couldn't fucking believe this,
but have you seen those rare taxis
that you can get in Tokyo?
- Rare taxis?
- No.
- I can't believe Japan
has actually done this,
but they've literally
turned taxis into Gacha.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- Of course they have,
of course they have.
- I forgot the exact name of it,
but I think it's called like
Sakura taxis.
- Right.
- So you know how like in most taxis
and this is only a Tokyo thing,
but like, you know how on taxis
they usually have like the
signs on top of the car
that like show whether the
taxi's open or whatnot.
- Yeah.
- Apparently out of, I
think the 7,400 taxi cars
in the greater Tokyo
area there are five taxis
that have a Sakura thing on top of it
and supposedly that's
like the SSR of taxis.
(laughing)
- What do you get?
What buffs do you get?
- No 'cause one of my friends
actually got it the other day.
- Yeah.
- And when you enter into the taxi,
it's lot, lot nicer,
and actually like a first class of taxis.
- Goddamn.
- And inside there's a
little sheet of paper
that says congratulations
you've found one of
five fortune red taxis.
(laughing)
- Fuck I hate that,
I think that's so fucking cool.
- Yeah, I think that's so fucking cool,
and I'm just like,
I really wanna kinda go around now,
trying to find this fucking
mythical taxi, this SSR taxi.
- Dude my fucking Gacha pull.
(laughing)
- Yeah right?
- It's the Gacha pool of taxis now.
(laughing)
- Garnt's frothing already.
- Oh my God.
- He's like oh my God.
- It's like every time
you use Tokyo taxi app,
you're just like come on give me the SSR.
(laughing)
- What is this like a 0.01 pull
or something like that?
(laughing)
Fuck it, i'll give it a go why not?
All right Connor let's get more taxis now.
- Garnt's just calling taxi
after taxi to his house
and they're all just parked out.
(laughing)
- It's like are you the rare taxi?
No, don't worry I don't need a taxi.
- It's like oh, fuck,
it's blue bag blue bag.
He's just like come on
give me the gold bag,
give me the gold bag.
(laughing)
Well I just think that's so fucking cool,
that's just like one extra I guess,
like piece of enjoyment you
can have as a tourist right?
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- Knowing that now when you come to Japan
and you go in a taxi, you
can look forward to that,
being like finna pull the SSR's off taxis.
- It's the one reason as a
tourist you should use a taxi
because Goddamn they're
expensive in Japan man.
- Oh in Tokyo they're fucking expensive.
- They get pissed off if you
take a short journey as well.
- Yeah.
- I've noticed that
sometimes I've had too much shit to carry,
so I've had to get like,
it's like a short walk from
the station to my house
but I remember like a few
times I've gotten the taxi
because I had like too
much stuff to carry,
they were like oh there?
Okay.
(laughing)
- Oh here this house.
- And then I say like
thank you when I leave
and then don't say it
back and I'm like wow.
Okay in Japan that's like
the biggest fuck you.
- Yeah.
- yeah.
- I'm like didn't say thank
you back, the audacity.
- That's like the equivalent
of flipping the book.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, literally.
Yeah.
(laughing)
I didn't realize that until
someone pointed it out
that it happened another time as well.
They were like wow that was
really rude, I'm like was he?
I thought he was just driving
(laughing)
- Well he didn't say thank you
back, what a fucking asshole.
- The first time it happened
was a similar situation
where it was a very short journey,
it was like an $8 journey not even right.
- Yeah.
- And then I got out and
the other person with me
was like wow that was so
rude. I'm like what was rude?
He just drove us he didn't say anything,
he's like yeah I said thank
you, he didn't say it back,
I'm like oh okay.
- The audacity of this bitch.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Ima finna get back in that car
and give him a slap you know.
(laughing)
- That's the thing, it's just Tokyo taxis
that are just so fucking expensive.
- Yeah.
- Because like
if you think about it catching
a taxi in Tokyo is a luxury
because trains are just so
fucking convenient in Tokyo,
whereas the moment you were
out of the greater Tokyo area,
a lot of places without a taxi
you're fucked.
- Yeah.
- I think it depends where you're going.
'cause there's some, if you're
on the outskirts of Tokyo,
if you're going in like an arc,
like a quarter circle let's say,
they don't really have trains
that go, like London right?
It's the exact same.
- Right.
- Where trains go in and
out and they don't go round
normally.
- Right, right.
- So if you wanna go the to outskirts,
most of the time to get like,
just a 15-minute taxi drive away,
it might require you to go
in, all the way to central,
and then go out.
- Yeah yeah that's true.
- That's like 50 minutes
and it's like well you know,
how much is 45 minutes of
my time worth or 30 minutes?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- But I think like the majority of people
- Central Tokyo.
- Just don't really.
- leave no excuse.
- Care about that.
- Yeah, I feel you're like
you know going to Shinju.
- Whereas in Okinawa, there's
literally one tram line
that goes for five stops
(laughing)
and that's the only
train line that they have
on the entire Island.
- Yeah.
- So that's why the taxis
are like half the price
that you get in Tokyo.
- Yeah if the people rely on it,
the local government will help insure.
- Yeah like a 30-minute
tax free ride in Okinawa
I was talking about was like 2000 yen.
- Oh shit seriously.
- Yeah it was really, really cheap.
- 'Cause in Tokyo that would be
about like 60, 70 bucks about.
- Yeah.
- I'm convinced right,
that in Tokyo they don't
make people retire,
they make them become taxi drivers.
(laughing)
- Yeah I swear most times taxi drivers,
when I see a young taxi driver,
I'm like wow you've made a career choice.
- Yeah I'm like something's up.
- You made a bold career
choice here what's going on.
- Because I speak to
people and I swear to God,
they look at taxi drivers
like McDonald's workers here.
- Yeah.
- Do they?
- Because it's like, you
don't need any qualifications
except drive, which you
know they expect you to do.
- Yeah.
- And it's just like a throwaway job
they make old G sons do.
- Yeah, yeah basically it's like,
I think the average age of a
taxi driver here is like 70
- It's like you can retire in Japan.
(laughing)
- You become a taxi driver?
- You wanna see yourself retire
or become a taxi driver.
- It's either taxi driver
or a construction worker.
- Um.
- But not actually.
- Oh yeah.
- Doing construction.
- Yeah.
- Just like holding the signs
(laughing)
and being like this way please.
- Yeah it's nuts how fast
they built houses here,
it's like crazy.
- Yeah we had like a whole school be built
right next to the apartment I'm living in,
- Mm-hmm.
- In the span of the
year I was living here.
- Jesus.
- Which is fucking insane.
- They built a full like
three-story house next to me
in like two months.
- Fucking hell.
- I was like what the fuck?
What the fuck this ain't right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- No it is crazy especially
like say when you go
into the city or whatever
and you haven't been
for maybe a couple of months.
(murmuring)
it's surprising the amount
of things that have changed.
- Yeah.
- You'd be like,
oh this building
(laughing)
was completely different two months ago,
now it's just magically here.
- Going back to taxi drivers though,
have you ever had any weird
or bad taxi experiences worldwide?
- Oh yeah definitely in Europe,
I've had some.
- In Europe.
- Pretty shitty taxis.
- Where in Europe?
- France.
- Oh.
- Oh okay.
- Was a taxi and Uber,
the worst Uber ride I
ever had was in France.
- I don't know why all the
weird taxi experiences I've had
have been in LA.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Like taxis or Ubers?
- Ubers.
- Ubers right.
- I like When they taught
you in LA, it's nice.
- Ubers in LA I've always
had a pleasant time.
- It's weird because I've
not for like the most part,
I've had very pleasant
experiences with Uber in LA
but sometimes I get a really
odd experience and it's.
Okay so the oddest experience
I've ever had with Uber in LA,
it was during AX time,
(clearing throat)
It was me and two other friends
and all we were doing was
we wanted to take a taxi
to the convention hall,
and this was late at night by the way.
- Mm-hmm.
- So it wasn't like the daytime,
it was like let's say 7:00, 8:00 pm,
so it was kinda nighttime,
the sun was down.
So we call this Uber and
this car just rocks up
and it's like a fucking decrepit
(laughing)
broken car.
- Oh no. I was just like.
- Shit.
- How the fuck has this passed
like Uber standards?
(laughing)
- I'm pretty sure that
like a dead body had been
in there at one point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
So we were like oh this is the Uber?
Oh okay so we were like whatever.
It's like a five, 10
minute journey anyway,
doesn't really matter that much.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- So we get in this taxi driver,
and immediately he opens his mouth,
and you can kind of feel
that he's not all there in the head,
(laughing)
he has a screw loose right?
- Right
- Why, What was he saying?
- So at the beginning
he was talking about,
guys I gotta ask you a favor,
can you please give me
five stars for my journey?
(laughing)
All I'm asking for is one five-star,
I just want a five-star okay.
I just keep getting one
stars and I don't know why,
I don't know why, I don't know why.
- He's like the one light kid.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's like we did it guys.
- And then I'm like okay
that's an aggressive way
to ask for a positive review but sure.
- That is not how you get five stars.
- Sure we'll give you a five star,
so he starts driving to
this convention hall right?
- Yeah.
- And he puts it in the GPS,
go to the LA Convention Center,
and then it says to go on a turning right?
- Yeah.
- And then it says please turn right,
doesn't listen he goes forward right?
- Right.
- So it's fine the GPS
corrects itself and goes
please turn right at the next turning,
ignores that one keeps going forward
and in between him ignoring this GPS
and getting further and further away
from the Convention Center I might ask,
'cause I was like on Google Maps,
'cause I was like What the is fuck
is this taxi driver doing?
And he goes and he keeps talking
about this fucking five-star
and one-star run right?
- Right.
- And he goes if I get another bad review,
I'm gonna lose it a man,
(laughing)
I'm gonna lose it.
- You're like hovering the one-star.
(laughing)
- He keeps saying that and
I'm just like making eyes,
'Cause I'm sitting in the front
and my teammate's sitting in the back
and I'm just trying to
make eyes to be like.
- Oh you're in the passenger seat?
- Yeah, so I'm just like,
- Oh, no.
- Yow if he pulls the gun
you've got my back, right?
- Yeah.
Like if something happens,
you've got my back.
And so the third time the
GPS tells to turn right
and he misses it again and
I'm just like shit man.
Something's gone wrong,
we need to get out of this taxi right now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'd rather get another Uber.
than get further and
further away from safety,
which is the Convention Center.
- Right, right.
- Than stay one second
longer in this taxi,
so we're like don't worry man,
we're close enough to
the convention center.
We can just stop here
and he goes are you sure?
And so we're just like
yeah, yeah please stop.
Please just stop here.
- I beg of you. (laughing)
- And so we get out of the taxi
and as I'm getting out he
leans over and he goes,
you're gonna give me a five-star, right?
And we go Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, five-star.
Five-star, You promise?
Five-star yeah, five-star.
(laughing)
And we're like yeah, yeah don't worry,
we'll give you a five-star.
All right looking forward
to that five-star,
drives off instant one-star.
(laughing)
- I was gonna say, I hope
you gave him one-star.
- Yeah, I hoped it was a one-star.
- 'Cause people are just like,
I don't care how nice you are,
you shouldn't fucking be an Uber driver
if you're pulling shit like that.
- That's the equivalent of
getting a pizza delivered
and the guy being like $20 tip right?
You gotta give me a least a $20 tip,
$10 no, no, no 20.
- But I could very much
see during that experience
why people gave him one stars
because I mean I kind
of feared for my safety
at one point during that taxi ride.
- I mean it's not even a matter of him
just like ranting about like,
I'm gonna kill a bitch if
I get another one-star.
It's the fact that he wasn't
even going the right way.
- He wasn't going the right way
and like I was like okay.
At the beginning when he
asked for the five stars,
I was like whatever it's a fucking review.
- Yeah.
- I don't give a shit
but when he was like
I'm gonna lose it man,
I'm gonna lose it.
(laughing)
I was just like oh shit man.
- That's fucking terrifying especially LA,
you don't know what the
fuck's gonna happen.
- Yeah exactly.
- Well that's pretty scary, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- I've suddenly haven't had any
of the crazy taxi journeys really
most of them are pretty chill.
I don't know I feel like it's really hard
to have a bad taxi journey.
Although someone gave me a one-star once
as a customer on Uber
and I was confused.
- Really.
- 'Cause I don't think I've
ever done anything in a car,
but maybe I did something that
like ruined this man's day
and he gave me a one-star.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah I know.
- I had one really
memorable Uber ride in LA,
and it was again from
where we were staying
to the convention center,
it was like again another
like five, 10-minute ride.
- Yeah.
- And this massive Jeep rocks up.
- Right.
- There's only two of us,
I'm like okay that's a
bit overkill but whatever.
- Okay.
- Jump in and just this like
the biggest black dude I've ever seen.
- Right.
- He's got like not like fat, like built.
Like he's got fucking
brick shit house all right,
and he's just like are you Joey right?
I'm like Yup and he's
like LA Convention Center?
All right I got you.
(laughing)
Like super chill right?
- Yeah.
- And so the car drives off,
like two minutes later he's like,
aye yo you mind if I put on some music?
(laughing)
I'm like yeah man
whatever you want right.
- Real nice circulation.
- Just like yeah man whatever you want,
it's all good and he's
like all right cool.
He turns on something right?
There's a million different artists,
you can envision a person like
that might listen to right?
(laughing)
- Just like oh yeah, just
like you know it could be any
fucking like hardcore
hip hop whatever right?
- Yeah.
- Whatever the dude's into,
fucking Enya comes on.
(laughing)
- Hell yeah.
- He's just like,
♪ Who can say where ♪
(laughing)
- Hell yeah.
- You can't just have a
fucking Terry Crews moment
and like white chicks.
- Yeah,
and I'm just like, I
just started laughing,
I couldn't help I'm like,
if I laugh this man might kill me,
but this is just too funny
and I'm like you like Enya huh?
And he's like, yeah helps me to relax.
(laughing)
- Dude that's fucking amazing man.
- Yeah it was fucking great.
- Full on respect to the dude.
- Yeah it was so cool.
That's the thing though,
I didn't know if he was
like trying to make me laugh
or he was actually being serious
but either way I was like,
you know what, I can get into this.
This is a really cool, you
know what props to you man.
(laughing) You may be brick
shit house but you listen
to some Enya whatever man.
- I'd love to be an Uber driver
and just troll people with music.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- I would as well.
- You mind if I put my favorite music on?
it just plays like.
- Lucky Star opening.
(laughing)
- No if I become an Uber driver,
anime ops only man.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Anime ops only.
- As I was hearing your story I was like,
have I ever given an
Uber driver a one-star?
I don't think so.
- That was my only one-star.
- To me it's like five-star is like
encompasses everything from
the best experience to my life
to you got me there in one piece.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Four-star is like you
literally broke down,
you shit yourself
(laughing)
the car stinks.
- Yeah.
- You've killed someone,
you hit a dog as well.
All right four stars.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I've just never used a one-star
I'm like didn't even
know it was an option,
you know I thought there were just two.
- There's zero-star as
well that you can give.
- Is there?
- Yeah I think so. (laughing)
(mumbling)
- What does someone have
to do to get zero-star?
- I mean like the worst Uber ride
that me and Aki went on
was in France, in Paris
and this dude like.
- You could Uber in France?
- Yeah.
- Fuck.
- And this man almost actually
got us into a car accident.
- Yeah french drivers are nuts dude.
- Yeah.
- I remember when I was I kid.
- He was fucking shouting
at everybody and like the shittiest kind
of like start-stop kind of driving
- (laughing) yeah.
- Where I'm just like,
bro I'm gonna be fucking
sick all over this car.
- Yeah.
- And he got us there and he was like
okay, okay we're here
for you know whatever,
and I was just like all
right man, zero stars.
- Didn't you get, you got
scammed in Italy right?
- Yeah almost.
(laughing)
- 'Cause like In like
Italy and a lot of European countries,
except for like I don't know,
Germany is pretty good for it.
I think, like Prague is really bad for it
and places like that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Where the taxi drivers mad scam you
and you gotta be like, it sucks,
'cause it's the most
un-Japanese thing ever.
But you just gotta be like,
no I'm not paying that.
- Give me an actual fare.
- Yeah.
- Like this is ridiculous.
- Yeah so we landed in Rome Airport
and there was just a
dude outside of the gate
just being like taxi, taxi.
- 'Cause they know you're tourists.
- Yeah 'cause they know
it's tourists right?
And we were with Aki's parents as well,
so Aki's dad was like,
yeah, yeah, yeah sure.
You know 'cause he's an Uber
driver right? (laughing)
- And he's like how much to this hotel?
And he looks and he goes uh 50 euros
and we're like all right whatever.
So then he takes us to like
the back of the airport
where it's like right
opposite where the hangar is.
- Right.
- And there's just this van,
(laughing)
and we get into this van and he's like,
okay hold on, I call my
driver and the guy fucks off
and we're left in this van
and the longer we look around this van
we're like we gotta get the fuck out
of this van dude.
(laughing)
Like this is not a taxi
because then I looked up like,
you know standard Italian taxi fares
to the airport from the hotel.
- Yeah.
- And we're like a normal
taxi ride is like 20 euros
and this dude's charging
50 and we're like,
we gotta get the fuck out.
- Don't fucking listen
to those in Europe man.
- Yeah.
- Like they'll try and get you away,
'cause there's always gonna
be an official taxi stand.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which you should
always go to.
- Yeah.
- So we immediately like, we
didn't even wait for the dude.
We just like grabbed our shit got out,
went to the regular taxi stand
and we're like all right thank God.
- I mean I'm pretty sure
for like any country,
you wanna go to the official taxi stand.
- Yeah.
- Well some countries
have way stricter rules
on taxis than others
and like even if you get
one somewhere random,
yes a lot of countries
you'll still get like.
I mean Japan you get it anyway,
you're gonna get the standard fare.
- Right, right, right.
- Right.
- Same in like Germany and UK as well,
I'm pretty sure it's all the same thing,
but yeah, it's.
- Yeah.
- Yeah we learned our lesson
and we were about to get.
I don't know where the fuck
this guy was gonna take us.
- Couple of you got in
someone's van. (laughing)
- Literally what they warn
against as you're a fucking kid.
- Yeah, right?
- Don't get in any van ever,
unless you're the one who's booked it.
- Well I think like the
craziest in terms of
taxi drivers I've had
are probably in China.
I remember there was this one taxi journey
I had in China where it
was literally like I was
in a crazy taxi game.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
Like this guy was full-on fucking,
he might as well have just been like
drifting initial D style.
- Right.
And he was like in the
middle of fucking Shanghai,
and whenever there would
be pedestrians on the road,
he wouldn't slow down.
He was like tapping his horn
like it was a fucking quick time event.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
- That's extra dumb shit.
- Like he literally had one
hand on the steering wheel
and the other hand on the horn,
'cause that's how often he tapping it man.
- My God.
- I had never like feared for my life.
- You go to Chinese driving
school and they're like,
right so roll the window down pre
so that you get ready to
shout at people (laughing)
and make sure your hand is
always on the middle, (laughing)
steering is optional.
(laughing)
- Jesus Christ.
- Oh my God man.
- I mean you told us
about the story before
about the situation that
was not (murmuring) right?
- Oh, yeah.
I've just had weird taxi journeys
what can I say.
- You have.
- It's just Asia seems to
have some weird fucking taxis.
- That's just Asia and driving rules
in general right?
- Oh yeah that's true.
(laughing)
- Which is why like we were talking
about bad taxi experiences in Japan.
I don't think I've had an even like
a bad mediocre experience in Japan.
Everything has just.
- No it's good.
- Got the job done.
- If anything the best taxi rides I've had
have been in country like Japan.
- In Japan right?
- Yeah.
- Everything's metered,
you don't have to worry about
tipping or anything like that.
I mean sometimes Japan
has been the only country
where I wish tipping culture was a thing.
- Yeah I wish it was a tipper.
- Yeah right.
- Because I wanted to tip that taxi driver
who took me on a tour
of different wineries.
- Yeah same.
- Without asking and stuff like that,
I'm like please let me.
- Lemme give you money.
- Give you extra money.
- Yeah we were all fully
prepared to like pay the extra,
because he was taking us
around the scenic route
and he's like no, no, no, no it's okay.
Stay the price, I'm
just like, bro come on.
- I want you to go home
tonight and treat yourself.
- Yeah exactly.
- Get something nice.
- Exactly.
- Speaking of like giving five-stars
and one-stars and stuff like that,
have we ever talked about
what the reviewing
mentality is here in Japan?
- It's just in terms of everything.
- I noticed that right
away when I moved here.
- Yeah.
- How like nothing on
Amazon is above four stars.
- Yeah.
- It's not just on Amazon,
like everything on Google Reviews.
- Google maps, yeah.
- Hardly anything is above four stars.
- Yeah.
- And if it is then it's
only like two reviews right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They do use Google Reviews
mainly for like restaurants and stuff,
but there's also a thing called Tabelog,
a lot of people who think
there food critics use.
- It's like the Yelp of Japan basically.
- Oh my God, it's insane,
'cause it's like these people
review these food restaurants
and like three stars for
restaurant is considered good.
- Yeah.
- And that's like it's done
it, it's impressive. (laughing)
- Because I remember when
I first moved to Japan
and whenever you'd look
up restaurants on Google,
you'd see like 3, 3.5 stars,
maybe the occasional 4,
- Yeah.
- And in England or in America
when I see a three-star restaurant,
I'm like yo something's gone wrong.
- If it's below a four then I'm
just like up with this place
- Someone found a rat in
their food or something man
like I don't know.
(laughing)
- I don't understand it's like,
do the Japanese think that
the stars on Google Reviews
is like Michelin stars?
- I mean I understand it
because they actually.
I respect that they have a mentality
where they literally actually use
every star in the review system.
- Right.
- 'Cause it's like the MAL review right?
- Anything below seven is shit.
- (laughing) Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty sure MAL users don't realize
that under five stars actually exists.
- Yeah.
- Because it's either
like seven if it's good.
- Six is really bad.
- Six is really bad
and like five is the most
(laughing)
awful anime you've ever watched.
- 'Cause for like a restaurant
the way I imagine it is like,
what would I tell the owner
if he was right in front of me now?
- Right.
- Like would I genuinely
sit there and be like,
this was a three-star experience,
(laughing)
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- How are you gonna do
that to the poor guy,
he's just trina run a business right?
- Yeah.
- It's 'cause to me you know,
if I go somewhere I really like the food,
I have nothing bad about it,
how in good faith can I be like,
yeah you don't deserve five stars.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause there was nothing wrong with it.
Like this was exactly what I wanted,
I got what I needed.
Yeah it wasn't fine dining,
it wasn't crazy but
there was nothing wrong.
- Sorry go on.
- Oh sorry
I was gonna say like that's
the thing I wanna ask
about these like super harsh
Japanese reviews right?
It's like what is a five-star?
- Yeah.
- It's like do you want
a blow job from the chef?
- Because this is also
another thing where like,
can you judge really a restaurant
the same way McDonald's?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Because what I was gonna say is,
even the fine dining restaurants
are the same star ratings,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that's because they
expect a fine dining experience,
so if they get the fine dining experience.
- That's standard,
that's normal.
you've done the job and
so that makes me wonder,
What the fuck would a
fine dining restaurant
have to do to get a four or five-star man?
- It blows my mind 'cause like I said,
like comparing McDonald's to
like a fine dining experience,
'cause they really shouldn't
be on the same scale right?
'Cause they're totally different things.
- Yeah.
- So when you go to McDonald's,
what are you judging about McDonald's?
Are you judging the place, the food?
What are you judging?
'Cause the food isn't gonna change really.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- It's probably not
gonna be any different.
- Yeah.
- The only thing
that determines a good McDonald's
experience or a bad one
is like how fast the food comes out.
- Yeah that's what I
see on Google Reviews,
i'll see a two-star McDonald's
and i'll see a four-star,
and I'm like what is the difference?
(laughing)
Like ultimately I cannot
tell the difference,
yes it might be dirty or whatever.
- I had three less fries
than I ordered last time.
- That's what confuses me
because then I'm also like,
okay so if I rate this
McDonald's a five-star,
what am I rating it a five-star on?
Am I rating it on a
five-star because I have.
- Compared to other McDonald's?
- Compared to you know.
- A bigger question is,
who the fuck is rating
McDonald's on Google?
(laughing)
Who are you people?
- Who is that boy?
- I don't do that. (laughing)
It must be okay not to
be rude but you know,
people who are like
yeah it's my only fine dining experience.
(laughing)
I will review every McDonald's I go to.
- People who call them
McDonald's a restaurant
are the same people will
call motels, hotels you know.
(laughing)
You know?
- I've noticed that every single
like really, really
high-rated place in Japan
like 4.5 or higher.
- Yeah.
- Is normally like a disgusting
wait time to get the food.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- Because when you get
to that star in Japan,
I feel like you get almost like a fandom,
like a hype around you.
- A cult following.
- Yeah and then everyone
starts telling everyone.
- It's like yo, yo this
has got a 4.5-star.
- You gotta go there
early, you gotta line up,
and it's like well fuck now
I can't enjoy the place.
(laughing)
There gotta make it a three-day
in-advance reservation.
- Yeah I noticed that as well,
Japan's restaurant culture
especially if something
is highly acclaimed,
it all spreads via word of mouth.
- The Japanese love lining up.
- Yeah.
- I don't know,
I don't get that.
(laughing)
They love lining up.
- As a British person,
I can appreciate a good queue.
- As a British person I can
appreciate a good queue as well,
but not to a restaurant.
- No, Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I can't fucking stand queues dude.
- Yeah if I wanna go to a good
restaurant that's exclusive,
please let me book it.
Please, Please.
- Yeah.
- I don't want another Gacha
system, I don't wanna line up.
I want just to have a booking
and a specific time I turn up
or you could be like us and
try to book a table at Denny's,
(laughing)
and completely fail.
- 'Cause we always eat Denny's
before we record a podcast
and we had one of the guests over
and we're like oh shit
that's a lot of people,
we might have to book a table at Danny's .
- Yeah.
- So we were like hey, Meilyne.
- Which to give context,
it's like trying to book
a table at McDonald's.
- Yeah.
- So Meilyne.
- You guys know Denny's.
- Called up Denny's
and was like uh can we
book a table for six?
and the guy came back and was like.
- This is a Denny's man.
- What is booking?
This is a Denny's.
(laughing)
Why are you trying to book
a fucking table? (laughing)
Just come to the restaurant, please.
- Man this is Denny's.
(laughing)
- Wasn't it like he called
like the manager or something.
- [Meilyne] Then he said like
wait I'm going to get someone,
he comes back and he was like
uhh this is Denny's we
don't do reservations.
(laughing)
- We don't do reservations.
- We don't do reservations
Yeah.
- This is a fucking Denny's.
- It's so exclusive, you
have to turn up on the day.
- It's the most polite
way you can just say,
it's a fucking Denny's why
are you calling for bookings?
- Yeah what the fuck's wrong with you?
- But also even like going
back to normal reviews
with products like all the
products are like that as well,
- and like.
- Yeah.
- If you see something
with fully five stars
on Amazon with over like 20 reviews,
you're like damn this must be the shit.
- Yeah.
- Or they're paying for those reviews.
- Yeah, yeah, true.
'Cause I remember when I was buying a,
going back last week, buying a bed.
I could not find a bed
over three stars on Amazon.
- No I couldn't either, I remember that.
- Like there was no bed
that was above three stars and I'm like,
how many problems are
people having with beds?
and I would go to the reviews
to read what they were saying
and they were all saying
that the build was too long
and that was the problem.
- That just sounds like your problem bro.
- I've had some of the
most pedantic reviews
on Japanese Amazon.
- They get so iffy wit it.
- I've had like someone one-star a product
because the packaging was bad.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a really common problem.
- The product's completely fine
the packaging was a bit off.
So they were like, one-stars.
- Yeah that's what drives me insane,
is that they almost
always review this shit
around what you're actually reviewing.
- Yeah.
- It's like oh the delivery
man had a bad attitude,
One-star.
(laughing)
- It's bullshit, if the
package is a little beat up,
but the thing's totally fine.
- Yeah.
- Fantastic.
- Yeah you're gonna throw
out the packaging anyway.
- Yeah.
- Who the fuck cares.
- I don't give a fuck,
as long as I can use the
thing I need so what?
This shouldn't be a blight on
the company that sent me it.
Like this is fucking absurd,
I guess I remember as I
brought it up to Chris as well,
'cause I was confused
and Chris was telling
me that Riotro told him
it's something like,
three is what you expect,
- Yeah.
- and it is good
and then five is like above and beyond.
- Yeah.
- To get five stars, it has
to be beyond exceptional,
like beyond what you wanted.
Whereas I think for me
five-star should be like,
all right this is what I paid for,
you gave me exactly what I asked for
no problems, five stars I
don't know weird, weird.
I guess it's different cultures.
- How do you guys feel
about seasonal products
here in Japan?
Because, you know every
country in the world has,
like seasonal products.
- Do we?
- And stuff but I feel.
- I guess so, yeah.
- It's just not as heavily
advertised as us here.
- But like Japan take
it to the next level.
Whereas half the shelf sometimes I feel,
is like seasonal products.
- Yeah everything is seasonal,
everything is premium as well.
- I mean I get it now,
I remember they would talk
about it in the anime.
They were like.
- (laughing) In the anime.
- They're like you don't know the pain
until your favorite item has
been removed from the Konbini.
- Yeah.
- And I feel that.
- I feel that as well
- Because so many items
that I just liked and for some reason,
the items that I specifically like
would just randomly get removed.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- From the Konbini,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I'd be like oh
it'll be back next week.
- Not gonna lie, every
time I walk into a Konbini
and I see something is like new.
- Yeah.
- I'm just like oh I might
grab one of those you know.
- I don't wanna try it, I
don't wanna get attached.
- Yeah, that's exactly
(laughing)
how I feel now.
- To be betrayed.
- I feel like so many
times living in Japan,
I go to a Konbini, I
try out this new product
that's only available for spring,
'cause it's like the spring special.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or the winter special
products try, absolutely love it
and then a few months later,
it just disappears.
- It's gone.
- I'm like fuck man I want it now,
you've given me a craving
(laughing)
and you've removed the craving
and now I'm gonna have to wait all year.
- For it to maybe come back.
- Yeah for it to maybe come back,
'Cause it might not even come back.
- I hate that when they like bring out
like a new Strong Zero flavor.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just like man this is way better
than the standard flavors
(laughing)
too bad it's only around for two weeks
and i'll never see it
again once it's gone.
- Yeah 'cause it's not just like items,
Sometimes there's like menu items
in like restaurants as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That are only available
during certain seasons.
- I mean I feel the
biggest problem with that
is that the one thing in Japanese
like especially supermarkets
and restaurants,
they love to do that whole like,
seasonal premium shit with fruits.
- Oh God.
- Right?
- We've gone out, we've ranted
about fruits so many times.
- We've ranted about fruits,
but like I remember like I went to uh.
I don't remember, no it was a Royal Host.
I went to Royal host
and they were doing this like
seasonal thing with grapes.
- Right.
- Like the green grapes.
- Oh yeah, I remember this.
- Like the muskets
and I tried a few of them
'cause I liked green grapes
and I was like oh this is really nice.
Went back the next week and it was gone
I'm like fucking hell, this
is really premium isn't it?
(laughing)
It's like I swear it was
only on the menu for like three days
(laughing)
and it's just gone.
- Yeah I swear they take
like limited time sales
to like another level here.
- Yeah.
- Because it feels like a lot of things
are just very limited.
It's a limited edition something,
it's a limited edition product.
- I mean you know one can argue
that that's like very good marketing.
- It is very good marketing I guess.
- Like people will look
at something premium,
being like well I guess
if I can only get it now,
I should get it now.
- It is kinda cool going into a place
and just having stuff being new constantly
but then there is also the fact of like
yeah I did really like this one thing
and you took it away from me.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- So I'm very attached.
- 'Cause it's like
the same thing whenever you
travel to a new prefecture
or something and there's every prefecture.
Like we talked about it before,
every prefecture has a specialty
and an item you can only
get in that prefecture.
- Every prefecture will tell you that,
this is the best rice in Japan.
Every prefecture will tell you,
it's all the fucking same.
- So like definitely living in Japan,
I've tried more,
like I've gone out of my comfort zone
with trying new products
and new sweets and new
foods and everything
but at the same time I've
just found more cravings
that I can't get on a
normal basis anymore,
(laughing)
Because it's only available
from a certain prefecture.
- What was the fucking maple
cakes that we bought from.
- Manju.
- Yeah the Manju that we
bought from Hiroshima.
- Oh, yeah.
- Those were so fucking good
but the problem is you can only buy them
in fucking Hiroshima.
So it's just like cool.
- Yeah I'm not really a sweet person
but then like we bought those,
and I ate one and I was like
fuck I wanna eat all of them.
(laughing)
- I was really pissed off
that I bought a tiny box.
- And I only bought
a tiny box fuck.
(laughing)
- Could have gotten the pack of 24
but instead I got the pack of eight.
- 'Cause you never know,
Sometimes you go you
try out this new thing,
you're like it's all right,
it's mid it's whatever right?
But sometimes you find
that really amazing product
and you're like fuck.
- Fuck I need it.
- But then on the contrary
isn't it amazing when you find
that one regional thing
that you think you're
never gonna see in Tokyo,
and then just one random shop sells it.
- Yeah true.
- Fuck yeah man.
- Fuck yeah,
like I remember in Tochigi for example,
they had this thing called Lemon Milk.
- Yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- which I fucking love, it
was a regional specific thing
for the longest time and
I was like well fuck,
I gotta make a trip up to
Tochigi every time I want this.
- Yeah.
- So I would always buy it in bulk
when I would come back home,
- Naturally.
- but of course it doesn't last, right?
And then the craving comes back
and I get fucking regressions.
(laughing)
But then I remember I walked
into like a random Konbini once
and they were just selling it.
- Right.
- And it was like fucking
El Dorado you know,
(laughing)
it was just like ah
the secret was here all along.
Fucking bought all that
shit then brought it back
and like all right note
put it on Google maps,
this is the Konbini that
sells the Lemon Milk.
- The Sapporo special thingy beer,
what is it?
What's it called again?
- Sapporo beer?
(laughing)
- No, no, no.
What's the prefecture called?
Hokkaido.
- Hokkaido.
- Hokkaido yeah.
- Pretty forgot for a second there,
yeah Hokkaidom the Sapporo
beer tastes way better
when they have like the
actual Sapporo beer.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It tastes so good,
I wanted to bring so
much back but it's heavy.
- Does it actually make
a difference, though?
- I genuinely think it tastes much better.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I think Sapporo in Japan tastes worse
than I remember it tasting abroad.
I don't know it's weird
maybe it's 'cause I have
it way more often now
but when I had Sapporo like.
- Hmm.
- On tap somewhere else I was like,
oh this is so much better than
the other beer that we have.
- Oh yeah, yeah
but I think it's because
you're comparing it
to other beers right?
Like I remember Asahi tasting
infinitely better in Australia.
- Yeah now it tastes shit.
- Now it tastes like shit.
- I don't know why.
- Yeah Asahi does taste bad.
- But now I'm more scared
to go back to Australia and
have the shit beer in Australia,
I'm like
(laughing)
if I think Asahi is mid now,
which used to be like God-tier before.
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna drink a VB right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like I feel like I'm gonna
throw up drinking that shit.
- I can't imagine going
back and going like,
drinking a Carling again.
- Oh God.
(laughing)
- Carling is like piss water in the UK.
- Yeah.
- It's like one of the worst beers
and there'll be sports bars in Japan
that are like we're
partnered with Carling.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I know.
- We sell Carling and Carlsberg here.
- I've seen that before 'cause.
- Or Budweiser.
- Yeah Budweiser.
- Yeah 'cause I've seen
like special restaurants.
They sell like this Thai
beer called Singha beer
and it's like in Thailand,
it's like the dirtiest,
cheapest beer you can get.
(laughing)
Like they don't even put it on tap,
they put it in like a can,
you know what I mean?
- Oh the tinnies,
the tinnies are the fucking worst.
- And in Japan they're on a menu,
like 500 yen for a little
can of Singha beer,
fresh from Thailand.
- Who is gonna go to Japan and be like,
oh we have exclusive Heineken
(laughing)
in bottle, 700 yen
please, it's like What no.
- Yo Heineken in Amsterdam
is fucking great.
- Yeah it's very good.
- Heineken in Amsterdam is good.
- Beer wherever it's brewed is the best.
- Well yeah.
(laughing)
It's like you know, I had a fucking uh,
oh my God I'm blanking
here the Irish one uh.
- Guinness.
- Guinness in Ireland is
like infinitely better.
- Guinness in Ireland does hits different.
- Yeah it's fucking amazing
but then I had a Guinness here on tap.
- Why would you do that?
- Because they were having it on tap,
so I'm like I was curious.
I was like all right well,
Guinness in Ireland is so good.
- I do that every time as well.
- Yeah I was like oh
they have Guinness on tap
here in Japan, let me see.
- Why'd you do it just to
get hurt all over again?
- Because you hold out the hope right?
- Yeah.
- You hold out the hope
of maybe this is the one,
maybe this is the place that recreate.
- It's like this pub
might be the SSR pool.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah exactly.
- It's like this might be the one.
- Maybe this is the one and
every time I get disappointed.
- It's never gonna be the one.
It's never gonna be the one.
- I was like every time I
see like Irish Pub in Tokyo,
I was like,
- Yeah.
- Is that the one?
Is that the one place that I can go?
- It's 'cause it's not even
Tokyo it's worldwide for me,
and like every time I
see a Guinness on tap.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it has to be on tap
never that canned shit.
- Oh no, no, no.
- But like it has to be on tap,
'cause I'm like it's on tap,
maybe this is the one.
Maybe they figured out the
secret and I'm still waiting.
If anyone in the world
has ever tasted a Guinness
outside of Ireland that tastes as good
as in Ireland.
- They're delusional
if they think so.
- Please, please hit me up.
- I need to know.
I need to know where that is.
- And I will literally travel
to that fucking place to try it.
- Why not just travel to Ireland Garnt?
- Well yeah i'll just go
to Ireland at that point.
- No I'm curious, I'm curious
to see if there's any place
outside of Ireland.
- It doesn't travel well you know?
That's the sad truth of it Garnt.
- It's like Kangaroo as well,
like that shit does not travel.
- I'm okay with that staying
in Australia actually.
(laughing)
- Dude I had a kangaroo steak
here in Japan at an outback steakhouse
of all fucking places.
- Why?
- Just 'cause I was curious
and I was like man this
shit does not travel,
(laughing)
I found that out on that day
that kangaroo does not travel.
- You know what's also bizarre?
When I was in Hokkaido,
I was at a train station,
and it was like 11:00 am.
- Hmm.
- Yeah.
- There were so many people drinking beer,
in the station.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Just like everyone every kind of like,
you know group you can imagine,
like young girls, old men, young men
they were all just
chilling in the station,
just drinking a Sapporo beer.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- I'm like this is weird right?
Everyone's just drinking
beer at like 11:00 am.
What the fuck?
It's in the train station
like the public waiting area,
it's just so bizarre.
- It's like that in Okinawa as well
but instead of beer it's alimony,
which is essentially just
really fucking strong shit,
it's basically Okinawan vodka.
That's the only way to describe it.
- I forget sometimes about
the public drinking laws here,
which you can drink publicly here,
because I feel like I didn't expect
to see so many people drinking
in the daytime in Japan.
Like I get surprised when
I see an Izakaya open,
because I'm like, who the
fuck is going to an Izakaya,
like 12:00 am for lunch.
- You'll see 'em and
they'll be drinking a Bevy.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I never thought that the concept
of like lunchtime beer was a thing here
until I saw it for myself.
- Yeah.
- And I was like wow,
they're actually having lunch and beer.
- And it's always like the
people you don't expect,
'Cause it's always like
the old people right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The old retired people,
who are just like hey, let's
just have a lunchtime beer.
- Yeah let's crack open
a beer like at 12:00 pm.
- To be fair in the UK, it's
all the old people do as well.
- Yeah, yeah it's true.
- If you ever go to
Wetherspoons at midday,
you'll always see the same
old people downing pints
at like 12:00 and you're like it's okay
they'll be asleep by 4:00 anyways.
- Yeah.
- Yeah it's true.
- It doesn't matter.
- Like speaking of like little seasonal
and regional stuff that
you can only get in Japan,
has there been anything you've,
like any little products
or anything you've missed from home
or from any other country at all
that you like actively get a craving for?
- You know I have Garnt.
- Oh man.
- I know you have Connor.
- My parents shipped
out Pot Noodles to me.
- Oh (laughing).
- Because I do like the ramen
cup noodles they have here.
- I die a little inside
whenever I hear Connor say that.
- Yeah.
- Because right?
I'm not saying that the
pot noodles in the UK,
which will be on screen,
are better than the ones in Japan,
I don't think that.
- All right.
- I think the Japanese ones
are superior in every way.
- Yeah.
- But there's something
familiar and comforting
about the flavor.
- It's nostalgia right?
- And also it's very spicy
which unfortunately.
- Oh.
That's hard to come by here.
- Yeah it's really spicy,
it's good shit, I love it
and so my parents for Christmas,
because you know ever since you
start making your own money,
it's like right I buy
everything I want for myself.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So they're like what can we get you?
And I'm like well you can get me something
I can't get myself.
- Right, right.
- And not love, none of that.
(laughing)
- Just send me Pot Noodles from the UK
and they're like Pot Noodles?
I'm like yes, please send
me Pot Noodles, so they did.
- Right.
- It was amazing.
- I always asked my parents.
- I teared up.
- To send me like Australian sweets
and something like that.
- Tim Tams perhaps?
- No we can get Tim Tams here.
- Well they suck anyway.
- What?
You don't like Tim Tams?
- Hello they're overrated.
Every Australian swears by them,
like it's national pride or something.
- It is national pride.
(laughing)
It's fucking awesome.
- It's just a biscuit.
- Oh my God get out of here.
- I think a biscuit is like,
the most underwhelming sweet.
Like it's hard it's never satisfying.
- It is.
- Like soft cookies are way better
than hard cookies as well.
- Yeah.
- What do you think Joey?
- Oh I get that, I get that.
But like we also have like.
Wait so do you guys consider
Tim Tams to be hard cookies?
- No biscuits.
- Biscuits oh hard biscuits, rather?
- Yeah there hard biscuits.
- Yeah, yeah.
What's the difference?
- 'Cause that's a soft biscuit to us,
'cause we have these things called.
- What you eating rocks for hard biscuits?
- We have these things
called Anzac cookies,
which are literally rocks.
- Like I don't wanna have to worry.
- Kids break teeth trying to eat these.
- I don't wanna have to worry.
- That's not a cookie.
- If I have to worry about breaking my.
- It is a cookie.
- If I have to worry about
breaking my goddamn teeth,
it's not a fucking cookie.
- Yeah.
Anzac biscuits are fucking.
Like Australians watching this would know,
Anzac biscuits are fucking awesome.
- It just sounds like a
health hazard with eggs.
- Yeah I don't want it.
- It is a health hazard.
- It's like chewing.
Dude you could work out your jawline
eating this fucking cookie.
Like it's so tough.
- We had these growing up.
I still have these in the UK obviously,
but they're called Digestifs,
did you like those?
- No.
- Suggestives?
- Digestif biscuits.
- Digestif biscuits
- What?
- Digestifs they're called.
- That is not appealing at all.
- I realized that's not
a very fitting name.
(laughing)
- They were awful, I never liked them.
- What's the fuck is a Digestif biscuit?
- It's just like the most
plain biscuit you can get
and it's got like a soft layer
of chocolate covered on top.
- And the chocolate is shit chocolate
and the biscuit is like just dry.
- Like a milk biscuit or?
- No, no, no, no it's
like a wheat biscuit,
yeah that's what it looks like.
- A wheat biscuit?
- Yeah.
- Oh God that doesn't look
good at all (laughing).
- Because you're supposed to like dip it
with tea and coffee and stuff like that.
- But then sometimes you dip it
in your hot tea and it falls apart
and your fucking tea's ruined.
- Yeah.
- But you can do that
with a Tim Tam as well.
- But I can't do that.
- That's too much chocolates
put in the tea basically.
There needs to be like a
perfect chocolate ratio,
chocolate-to-biscuit ratio,
'cause Tim Tam's like
covered in chocolate right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's too much.
- If the chocolate starts melting
on your fingers as you dip it
in tea that's like too much.
- You never done a Tim Tam straw before?
- What the fuck is that?
- That's like a thing
like you do in Australia.
- So Joey is like you never
done a flip flop kangaroo?
- Here's some Australian
culture for you all right?
So you get a Tim Tam, it
says usually you do it
with a cup of tea.
- Yeah.
- Or a cup of coffee
or whatever you prefer,
you get a Tim Tam you bite both ends off.
- Right.
- And then you use it as a straw
to suck up your tea and coffee
and it's awesome.
(laughing)
- Is this some down under joke?
Us in the up and over don't care.
(laughing)
Like what the fuck?
- The up and over (laughing).
- When is something a culture
and when is it just like stupid?
(laughing)
- It's what we do, that's
what some people do.
I did it once and I was
like yeah it's cool,
I don't do it every time
but it's just a little thing
(laughing)
you can do.
- Yeah I don't know.
- We gotta find our own
fun in Australia, right?
There isn't a lot to do.
- (laughing) Exactly.
- All right.
- But yeah I don't like biscuits at all.
- No it's definitely like the worst.
I'm not really fond of cookies either,
I think cookies are overrated.
- Maybe it's just because
UK cookies are just shit.
- No, no, no, no.
- No, no, no.
- No it's not
I've had cookies everywhere.
(laughing)
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
- Come on.
- The fucking store brand
cookies are always shit,
fresh cookies out the oven.
When they're like,
they need to be.
- Soft, soft, soft.
- Soft and chewy I do not.
Okay my favorite cookies I can get
are actually subway cookies.
- Oh okay yeah there bomb.
- Subway cookies are
fucking great.
- I get it, I get it
You like the ones where you can pull it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Easily off yeah I like that,
that is the best, good.
- If it's not fresh out the oven,
What I hate is if I bite in
a cookie and it crunches.
- Shit goes everywhere,
crumbs annihilate the room.
- If I have crumbs then I'm
like this, I this is a cookie.
This is just a biscuit with extra steps,
you know what I mean?
- Just a biscuit with attitude.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I
like my cookies to be gui.
- Yeah.
- I like it to be soft.
- Not gonna lie I've never thought
that deeply about biscuit in my life.
- I have.
- I have because you grow up
in the UK you're watching
American cartoons
and for some reason in American
cartoons cookies are like
like I don't know the thing
that fueled the world,
(laughing)
for kids generation.
- Right.
- Cookies were what like
the Mayans used to barter
and negotiate these kids
shows me cookies to be
like the godsend of like everything.
So when you grow up and you can
stop buying your own things,
you're like well.
- Yeah.
- I mean cookies are the best treat,
then you start having them.
You're like wait these are kind of shit.
it was always like you know
that mythical cookie Jar right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah cookie jar.
- I didn't have it in my house,
so I assume everybody else has one.
- It was just like cookies were
like insanely like valuable,
you know kids were dying
fighting wars on the playground
- Like currency (laughing)
- Yeah literally it's you know?
- Cause like for me whenever
I get like baked cookies
or someone who cooks fresh cookies
there's like as soon as
it comes out the oven
the timer fucking timer starts.
- Yeah cause when it's dry it's shit.
- Yeah exactly cause you gotta be like.
- 100% cookie speed right?
- I gotta like enjoy this
before it starts hardening
and it's like as soon
as it starts hardening,
it's one of the few objects in the world
where moist is a positive adjective.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
- No I get that, I get that.
- I feel bad when people like make cookies
like the day before and they bring them
and there like you wanna try
one of my home baked cookies,
I'm like I could.
- Yeah.
- I could try one of
your home baked cookies
but I will be sorely disappointed.
- Like those and brownies like
if I have like a dry brownie
it's like the
limp dicks of brownies.
(laughing)
- A brownie does need to be a little like.
- Wet.
- yeah, yeah.
- Moist.
- Yeah.
- If it all just fucking
crumbles apart though
when I touch it I'm like well.
- Yeah.
- The structural integrity
of this brownie is appalling.
- If it's flaky then it's too dry.
- If it's not making like a nkt, nkt sound
as it should you know.
(laughing)
If it's not making that sound
then it's a bad brownie, you feel me.
I can't be the only one that thinks that.
(Mumbling)
It needs to be like ASMR levels of
like lips smacking in your ears.
- Did your supermarkets in Australia
like have bakery sections
where they would bake things?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah we did.
- In the UK to be fair,
they used to make pretty fucking
good cookies and brownies.
Do you not think so?
- Sainsbury's.
- Sainsbury's would have their own bakery.
- Okay I know the best ones
he goes Sainsbury's then
Tesco's then Coop cause those.
- Do these all sound
like just made up names?
- Yeah they do.
(laughing)
- These are the supermarket
chains in the UK
all of them have their own bakery.
- Yeah.
- And like you get like four
fat ass cookies for a pound.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they were always like
freshly baked on the day
and soft and they were fucking good.
- They were good cookies.
- You could buy the like
packaged ones but like
why would you do that when you could go
and get like a full box of brownies.
- Yeah.
- Like 16 little chunks for like quid.
That's a no brainer.
- Right and there
freshly baked.
- Freshly baked.
- Yeah.
- Really fucking good.
- Yeah that sounds way better.
- Yeah i'll tell you what I do miss
that I didn't think I
would dairy milk chocolate.
- Yeah I liked dairy milk chocolate.
- Because I thought whenever I came
to Japan on holiday and
stuff I was like man,
the chocolate here's bomb.
I fucking loved the
taste of chocolate here.
And then after living
here a year I just feel
like I've really something
homely about dairy milk.
- No they've taken the American
way of making chocolate.
- It does taste like American chocolate.
- Because what they've done
is instead of having more milk
and making it like a richer
taste they're like hmm
let's just substitute with more sugar.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you get this kind
of weird chemically taste
which I like, Hershey's.
Hershey's tastes like in my mind
like question marks with sugar.
It's like I don't know
what this tastes like,
it doesn't taste like chocolate,
it tastes like a made up.
- I am not a fan of Hershey's at all.
- American chocolate does
not taste like chocolate.
- I used to like really like Hershey's.
- Really?
- I still kind of do
whenever I'm like in the UK.
- It's not as rich, so
you could eat more of it.
- Yeah because what Hershey's tastes like,
it tastes like cooking chocolate right.
- Hmm.
- Oh like the melting chocolate.
- And I don't know why as a kid
I fucking loved cooking chocolate.
- Well is normally for poorer quality.
- Yeah yeah exactly.
(laughing)
It's poorer quality but as a kid,
I just like anytime we'd cook chocolate
I just like always have
to dip my finger in it.
- Oh yeah of course.
- Give it a quick taste
and that's what Hershey's tastes like.
So as an adult eating
Hershey's like brings me back
to being a kid and then I have two bars
and I'm just like okay
this is actually just shit.
(laughing)
nostalgia gone it's
just shit chocolate now
- Like American fan,
you have it rough man,
I know we clown you guys
all the time (laughing)
but like your chocolate is fucking awful.
Please like import
some like milker or dairy milk
- Cadbury.
or something yeah.
- Cadbury milk chocolates
are the fucking best.
Cadbury's is dairy milk right?
- Yeah.
- I think it's owned by
an American company now.
(laughing)
But it used to be I mean
a lot of the British
chocolate's really good.
I think that's one
of the things we actually did pretty well.
(murmuring)
Yeah I think chocolate in the
UK is really fucking good.
- I think chocolate all over Europe
is pretty damn fucking good.
- You guys get it from Europe.
- But it gets hella bougie
and then like the rest of Europe and like
- Swiss chocolates and stuff.
- Swiss chocolates is fucking great.
- It's great but it's
like seven bucks sometimes
for like a small piece .
- It's great but every time
I have a bite of Swiss chocolate,
I can feel the chocolate
entering my veins.
- Yeah it's a very intense.
- It's so rich.
- Depends 'cause I think my favorite like
big brand Swiss chocolate is like Lindt.
- I do like Lindt.
- Lindt's really good.
- But you gotta like sit
down after you have a bite.
(laughing)
You're like arg.
- It's fucking great.
- It's like doing a pint of cocaine.
- It's fucking is you go on a journey,
when you take that one bite man,
when like the truffle inside
is just like the perfect consistency.
- No, no, no, no.
- When you bite off the hard shell
and it just the soft truffle
and it's just like ah, it's beautiful
and my mouth is watering
just describing it.
- I fucking love a good Ferrero Rocher.
- Oh Ferrero Rocher, oh my God.
- Yes Goddamn.
- Ferrero Rocher is fucking amazing.
- Ferrero Rocher milkshakes
are like the best thing ever.
- Ferrero Rocher's ice cream
is fucking good as well.
- You can like grind it
into like a milkshake
and it's fucking amazing.
- Oh like DIY.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh wow.
- Some places do it.
- Really?
- I feel like I increased the clause,
Whenever I say Ferrero Rocher.
- Yeah.
- It's someone's porscheous word,
I can think of off the top of
my head and it sounds so good.
- I can feel the molecule
forming on my eye.
(laughing)
- I do need to top hut every
time I say Ferrero Rocher.
- Ferrero Rocher.
- 'Cause I feel like you
experience Swiss chocolate,
you don't eat Swiss chocolate.
- No.
- You know what I mean?
You eat British chocolate,
like it's something you can just eat.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
- The Swiss don't do
drugs they do chocolate.
- Oh man sometimes I like
buy like a packet of Lindt
and I'm just like I'm
having a good day today.
- Can you eat all of the
Lindt package in one go?
'Cause I can't like
'cause I feel like I
need a pallet cleanser,
every time I have like a rich chocolate
I'm like give me the wine to go with it,
(laughing)
to empty the flavor.
I have like the problem where
I have one, it's enough.
- You have a sweet
tooth though, don't you?
- I do not have a sweet tooth actually.
- Bull shit you do.
- I don't.
- You always snack on sweets.
- Only in Japan actually
'cause here's the thing
I hardly ever use the snack,
I either was that guy in England
who would eat a tub of ice
cream or go without sweets
for like two weeks.
There was no in between
for me like only in Japan,
have I ever like kind of
embraced snacking culture
and that's just because there are so many
different kinds of sweets and snacks here.
- Yeah.
- They're like kina wanna
try something every time.
- I used to be a sweet's
guy back in Australia
but then when I moved here I realized
that Japan's snack or
like confectionary section
there's a lot more savory shit.
- Yeah.
- That just tastes way
better than the sweet shit.
- Yeah.
- So I always just go
for the savory shit now.
- It's easier to make
something that's tastes good
that's sweet though.
You just fucking put a shit
ton of sugar and call it a day.
- Yeah but I also feel gross
after eating it too right.
- 'Cause if you ever come
to my house in England,
if you ask for like anything
that's not savory snack,
I'm probably not gonna have it
because if I do have a
lindt, like a chocolate
or like a lindt box that's gone
in like a few hours
(laughing) most of the time.
That's cause I rarely buy but when I do
I'm like super craving it I dunno.
- I mean I haven't had a Ferrero Rocher
in like probably like a year
and a half maybe two years.
- Do they sell them in Japan?
- Oh yeah.
- They do.
- Yeah.
- I've never see them.
- If you go to like international
shops they'll have it.
- Because like in the UK that
was like the not expensive,
it's like the if you wanna look expensive
but not actually spend too much money
Ferrero Rocher's with it.
- Everything about Ferrero Rocher
it just looks fucking porsche.
- It looks fancy,
it sounds fancy. But the
only thing that isn't fancy
is like the price tag, I
mean they're expensive,
but compared to like Lindt or Leno
something like that it's like no.
- I've had some super super.
You're talking about
Lindt and Ferrero Rocher
being like a really like deep taste.
- Ferrero Rocher aren't that intense.
- I've had some like the
super expensive chocolates
are the ones I feel like
you're going on a fucking battle
with taking a bite out of this man.
- Ferrero Rocher is like
the premium of economy.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- It's just a little
bit better than normal.
- Have you ever had
like truly like you gone
to like a specialist
chocolate shop kinda shop.
- Yeah.
- And tried one
of those chocolates.
- They always give you
like the super intense
like dark chocolate 'cause
that's like the purest form
and then I eat this and I'm like
yeah tastes like fucking ash.
(laughing)
- But do you like dark choc flavor?
- I do but there's a limit like.
- Right it's like 90% cacao.
- 'Cause you'll go to places
like chocolate tier places
and they'll be like
it's amazing, isn't it?
And it's like 80% like a cacao.
And then you're like (throwing up)
it's great, it's great.
(Laughing)
- Sometimes I have like
one bite and I'm like,
oh I've gotta fucking battle this.
- I need like two here.
- I'm having a fucking
battle with my mouth,
like trying to get this done man.
- Like I get it if I was
having like an espresso
or something to go with it
like perfect they'll wash each other out
and you know i'll feel happy.
But when you have one bite
of super dark chocolate
it fucking stays with you
for the rest of the day.
- Yeah it does.
- You cannot get the
taste out of your mouth.
- Yeah.
- And I don't wanna feel like
I've just bleached my mouth.
- I've never thought
about having chocolates
with like anything else actually.
- Really? It's with
coffee, it's like the best.
- Yeah you can have it with a coffee.
- I don't eat chocolate
less it's with a hot drink.
- 'Cause for me coffee and
tea I just like by it's self,
I've never tried, 'cause
if you dip something
into the tea that kinda
like changes it's taste.
- No I don't dip in it, I eat it.
- You eat it with it.
- You eat it and then
you drink it.
It's like a palate cleanser.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause like if your mouth is too chocolaty
you can't keep eating more chocolate.
- I might wanna give
that a go then because.
- Did this man never
thought to combine the two.
- No because I never yeah
I never thought about it.
(laughing)
- Chocolate and tea unspeakable.
- 'Cause chocolate was
always been a snack for me
that I help myself.
- Why do you think that
at like a fancy restaurant
there'll be like coffee and dessert.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Garnt's like ah ah what?.
- Coffee and Chocolates.
(laughing)
- Yeah 'cause they go together.
Garnt's just like wow I didn't know that.
- I thought you're supposed
to eat all the chocolate
and then down your tea.
(laughing)
- Are you telling me chocolate's
meant to be just a snack.
(laughing)
and not just a dessert.
'cause I guess that's
where I see all chocolates.
- Right, right.
- Like I said I never used to snack,
It's like it was my dessert I guess
it was like a full on
I'm either committed.
- Feels very sad to have a chocolate bar
and be like ah yes dessert.
- My dessert.
(laughing)
- Yeah 'cause like,
I actually like didn't start enjoying wine
'cause as a kid or as like
a teenager I would say
wine was like the one alcohol
that I just couldn't get into.
- Yeah same.
- I didn't understand
why people liked wine
and then I remember the
first time I tried red wine
or good red wine with good steak
and it was just like an instant
eye opening moment for me man.
- I mean let's be honest,
you can't really enjoy wine
unless you have a bit of
disposable income really?
(laughing)
I don't know about you growing up
but parents would like to
think that's a waste of money.
Which is fair enough.
- I mean unless your here.
- Even before whenever you know
you'd go out with your family
or you're one of your rich you
know relatives or whatever.
And you try this good expensive wine
and the only thing you can think of
this isn't fucking worth 80 bucks.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Are you're kidding me.
And to be honest I still think that
I still think any like,
I'm probably making some similar cry here
but I've never tasted like a wine above
then let's say 50 bucks that
has tasted a lot greater
than some of like the best wine
you can get in any other price.
- Yeah like a $60 wine tastes
the same to me as like a $200 wine.
- Yeah exactly.
- I mean I've heard like you can buy wine
at convenience stores here for
like as cheap as four bucks.
- It's not good wine though.
- That's really bad.
- I can taste the difference between that
but like the more expensive
quote-unquote wines
that you can buy like
a 711 is like 1000 yen
and those are actually perfectly fine.
Like I've had a few of
those where I'm just like,
you know what?
This is actually pretty
good for 1000 yen wine.
- I don't know.
- It's good for colombini
wine that's what i'll say.
- For colombini wine it's
the best you're gonna get.
- Shout out to Alpaca wine,
What's like the equivalent
of like the cheap one?
- Echo falls.
Alpaca wine is like the
Echo falls of Japan.
- And in the UK it's
the cheapest wine brand.
- Like a box wine?
- There is a box version.
- It's the uni brand.
- Oh uni wine.
- It's about four pound
for a bottle and it's like always flavored
like a kids drink
(laughing)
it's like lemon and grapefruit
and it just tastes like
anti-freeze with grape hint.
- Yeah we have that in Australia
just tastes like washing
detergent grape flavored.
- Yeah it's fucking awful.
- It's fucking gross.
- But you know what else I'm grateful for?
- What?
- Our patrons.
- Oh my God they're awesome.
- Oh my God.
- Look at all of them.
- Wow shout out to that guy
on the screen right now.
- They like eating chocolate and wine.
- I bet they do.
- They hate hard biscuits.
- This guy is a similia.
- They think biscuit's mid.
(laughing)
- They hate taxi rides.
- Thank you for that.
- Just talk about
everything we talked about
and there like yes can you relate.
- They hate anime themed cafe.
- Yeah, yeah they hate that.
- Oh yeah we did start
off on that, didn't we?
- Thank you for joining us
today on the Trash Taste
Garnt do you wanna share?
- And again contractually
because we have to say it,
thank you to G-Fuel
(laughing)
for sponsoring this episode.
- Hey if you'd like to
support us on Patreon
go to patreon.com/trash taste,
also follow us on Twitter and subreddit
and a for audio listeners
go over to our Spotify.
- And yeah Joey literally said everything
that I needed to say.
- Do the outro.
- Thank you for taking the
host spot from me Joey.
So I guess we'll,
- I've been your host Connor.
- Fuck.
- Have a nice episode.
- I've been your host Joey as well.
- Bye-bye.
- Guys I wanted to say the outro.
(gentle music)